Es geht um alle möglichen Arten von Gewalt, die uns geschildert wurden. Es gibt in einigen Fällen starke körperliche Gewalt, es gibt psychische Gewalt. Es ist immer wieder die Rede davon gewesen, dass sie vor allem zum Schweigen gedrängt wurden. Immer wieder wurde ihnen klargemacht, dass sie nicht sich an irgendjemanden wenden sollen, der außerhalb dieser Fußballwelt steht. Also bitte nicht zur Polizei gehen, natürlich nicht in Medien darüber reden. Am besten sollten sie, wenn es überhaupt passiert, sich dann innerhalb der Fußballwelt, also vielleicht an den Berater, vielleicht an den Spieler selber wenden und dort Gesprächspartner suchen.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer zu Tribünengespräch Nummer 47. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Wir haben heute ein wichtiges Thema vor uns. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter. Und ich freue mich sehr, hier zwei Journalistinnen begrüßen zu dürfen, die eine sehr wichtige, wie ich finde, Recherche mit vollbracht haben. Zum einen Gabriela Keller vom Correctiv. Sie heißt auch Edgabriela Keller auf Twitter. Ich kann sehr empfehlen, zu folgen. Da wird auch so einiges noch passieren. Hallo Gabriela, schön, dass du hier bist. Und ebenfalls hier ist Maike Backhaus, Freisportjournalistin, die auch auf Twitter ist, als Ed Maike Backhaus. Also es ist denkbar, einfach ihr zu folgen. Auch das solltet ihr tun. Hallo Maike.
Hi Max, ich freue mich auch sehr, nur damit da keine Erwartungen enttäuscht werden. Ich bin keine Sportjournalistin. Tatsächlich ist es das erste Mal, dass ich mich um die Ecke einem Sportthema so sehr nähere. Aber ich denke, es wird nicht das letzte Mal bleiben. Insofern, who knows.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir das später auch noch mal thematisieren, ob das wirklich eine Enttäuschung ist, wenn jemand nicht Sportjournalistin ist, sondern nur Journalistin oder ob das nicht vielleicht sogar ein Gütesiegel ist.
Ja, genau. Ich wollte sagen, ich komme dann eher – ja, genau. Aber einfach, dass das jetzt eine Expertise ist, die ich mir selber noch nicht direkt umhängen würde.
Also es gibt keine Tweets zu Augsburg-Wolkburg bei dir?
Nee, genau. Ich denke, wenn ich meine Twitter-Karriere starte, wird das eher in Richtung von investigativen Journalismus gehen. Genau, vielleicht auch mal politisch und wirtschaftlich angehaucht, aber genau dem Sport nähern wir uns hier jetzt gerade erst mit dieser Recherche.
Ja, es wird um sportliches gehen und um viel nicht sportliches hier. Bevor wir loslegen, muss ich aber natürlich wie immer ein paar Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützer des Rasenfunks danken. In diesem Fall sind das Paul aus W, der Löser, ganz liebe Grüße, der Lange, Ex-Wuschel, Krausi und Hagi 1857. Sie alle unterstützen den Rasenfunk finanziell. Der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt paywall und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung, die ihr unter rasenfunk.de slash supporters club ableisten könnt. Na, das war falsch formuliert. Also, ihr könnt uns da unterstützen oder über kiosk.rasenfunk.de. Und das habe ich in den letzten Folgen, die schon mit Correctiv-Gästen stattgefunden haben, nicht bedacht. Ich wollte an der Stelle auch noch offenlegen, ich bin Unterstützer des Correctivs schon seit Ewigkeiten. Ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwas ändert, aber weil ich ja immer Transparenz einfordere von allen anderen Akteuren, muss ich natürlich auch transparent sein. Also, das sollt ihr wissen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich unterstütze das Correctiv und wir reden hier über eine unter anderem Korrektivrecherche. Und bevor wir dann loslegen, noch ein letzter Hinweis. Es kann sein, dass es in dieser Folge auch triggende Elemente geben wird. Wir sprechen über häusliche Gewalt. Zwei Dinge sind dafür wichtig. Zum einen, wenn ihr davon betroffen seid oder generell einfach dieses Thema ein wichtiges in eurem Leben ist, dann könnt ihr zum Beispiel auf hilfetelefon.de anonym euch Informationen holen und auch Beratung. Es gibt auch ein telefonisches Beratungsangebot unter 08 116 016. Alles wird in den Show Notes verlinkt und ich werde es so machen, wie zum Beispiel beim Tribünengespräch zum Machtmissbrauch in der NWSL, der US-Frauenfußball-Liga, dass ich Passagen, in denen triggende Elemente vorkommen könnten, die werde ich mit Kapitelmarken markieren. Da steht dann ein TV davor und wenn ihr davon betroffen seid, dann könnt ihr diese Passagen so überspringen und dennoch diese Folge hören. So, das reicht jetzt aber der Vorrede, denn wir haben ein wichtiges Thema vor uns. Maike, Gabriela, ich weiß gar nicht, wer von euch anfangen will. Sagt uns doch mal grob erstmal, worum geht es denn bei dem, was ihr da recherchiert habt über viele Monate?
Wir haben uns beschäftigt mit einer Reihe von Fällen von Spielerfrauen, früheren Spielerfrauen, die sprechen über verschiedenste Formen der Gewalt und des Machtmissbrauchs. Wir haben Fälle, wo Frauen über erhebliche körperliche Gewalt sprechen, Schläge, Tritte, Würgen. Wir haben aber auch Fälle, wo sich die Gewalt eher auf psychischer Ebene äußert, wo Frauen unter Druck gesetzt bedroht werden. Wir haben eine ganze Reihe Fälle, wo es eher um ein starkes Kontrollelement geht. Das ist so ein Thema, das sich so ein bisschen durchzieht. So ein wiederkehrendes Motiv, dass die Art der Gewalt, die ausgeübt ist, viel zu tun hat, damit die Frauen zu kontrollieren. Das äußert sich auch darin, dass mehrere der Frauen, die wir gesprochen haben, fürchtet, dass sie ausgespäht werden, dass sie überwacht werden. Das geht bis hin zu Tracking von Fahrzeugen, Hacking im Internet. Es geht um ein starkes ökonomisches Machtgefälle, was tatsächlich auch ausgenutzt wird gegen diese Frauen und was immer wiederkehrt. Und was, glaube ich, charakteristisch ist für diesen gesellschaftlichen Bereich, in dem wir unterwegs waren, dass der Druck zu schweigen ganz erheblich ist und sich auch auf verschiedene Arten äußert. Und zum Beispiel passiert das auf juristischem Weg, vertraglichem Weg mit sogenannten Verschwiegenheitsverpflichtungen. Aber es gibt durchaus auch andere Arten, die Frauen zu kontrollieren, nämlich mit Hilfe von eben Drohungen, wirtschaftlichem Druck, damit das Selbstbewusstsein der Frauen systematisch erschüttert wird mit Aussagen wie, dir glaubt doch ohnehin keiner. Und eben auch auf medialer Ebene, weil die Spieler und ihre Berater und Manager zum Teil sehr gute Kontakte gerade zu großen Boulevard-Medien haben und das dann auch einsetzen oder einzusetzen drohen.
Und uns ging es insofern, genau wie Gabriela jetzt gerade sagte, vor allem um den strukturellen Machtmissbrauch darin. Also natürlich geht es um die Taten der Fußballspieler in der Beziehung auch darum, aber es geht vor allem darum, wie diese Strukturen dazu führen, dass die Frauen keine Hilfe bekommen, sich keine Hilfe holen können. Und die normalen Strukturen, die eigentlich gesellschaftlich dafür vorgesehen sind, nicht greifen. Und wir haben sozusagen anhand dieser Beispiele skizziert, warum das so ist, warum in diesem Machtgefälle, in dieser Industrie, in der einfach auch wahnsinnig viel Geld steckt, dann sozusagen diese Bedürfnisse oder diese Hilfsstrukturen nicht mehr funktionieren. Insofern ist es für uns nicht so sehr eine Geschichte von Profi-Fußballer gegen Spielerfrau, sondern eben ein struktureller Machtmissbrauch in dieser Industrie.
Und wie seid ihr da auf den Fußball gekommen? Also, dass es da ein Machtgefälle gibt, das ist ja klar. Überall, wo einzelne Menschen viel Geld haben und wo es auch so ein gewisses Geklüngel, würde ich sagen, unter den Akteurinnen gibt, da ist sowas natürlich virulent. Aber ihr müsst ja auch irgendwie einen Anfang eurer Recherche gehabt haben.
Also, ein Machtgefälle muss ja nicht immer gleich zu einem Machtmissbrauch führen. Das hat sich aber halt in unserer Recherche sehr, sehr stark dargestellt. Ich bin über den Fall Kascha-Lehnhardt darauf aufmerksam geworden. Der wurde ja medial sehr intensiv besprochen, aber unter einem ganz anderen Gesichtspunkt. Der stand da als tragischer Einzelfall und in Bezug auf Cybermobbing wurde das ja sehr, sehr stark besprochen. Und ich bin da tatsächlich an diesem NDA und dann dem Interview, was Jérôme Boateng bei der Bildzeitung gegeben hat, hängen geblieben und habe mich dann auch diesen NDAs genähert. Und dann haben wir unsere Recherche zusammengefügt. Und Gabriela hatte noch mal da einen anderen Ansatz.
Genau, das war eigentlich ein großer Glücksfall für uns beide, glaube ich. Wir haben unabhängig voneinander angefangen, das Thema aufzugreifen. Also bei mir war es so, dass wir einen Hinweis hatten. Es fing bei mir an mit einer Frau, die schon eine sehr starke Geschichte hatte. Und für mich war das Hauptproblem dadurch, dass es wahnsinnig tabuisiert ist und die Frauen sehr stark eingeschüchtert sind und ihre ganze Geschichte dahingeht, dass ihnen immer gesagt worden ist und immer vermittelt worden ist, dass sie keine Chance haben und wenn sie sich anfangen zu wehren, dass dann alles viel, viel schlimmer für sie wird. Das hat alles begraben unter so einer dicken Decke aus Angst und Schweigen und Bedrohtsein. Und da an die Frauen ranzukommen, das war irrsinnig schwer. Und das hat tatsächlich viele, viele Monate gebraucht. Letztlich ist es uns gelungen, insgesamt neun Fälle zu recherchieren, wobei wir nicht mit allen der Frauen direkt gesprochen haben. Der Name Kasha Lehnhardt fiel schon, mit der konnten wir natürlich nicht mehr persönlich sprechen, weil sie offenbar Selbstmord begangen hat. Am Ende hatten wir aber diese neuen Geschichten, die wir recherchieren konnten. Das war für uns so ein Moment, wo wir gesehen haben, das sind nicht nur Einzelgeschichten, da gibt es bestimmte Elemente und Muster, die immer wieder auftauchen und immer wieder dieselben Reaktionen auf bestimmte Vorfälle vorkommen. Das war für uns eigentlich das Erschreckende, dass die Geschichten, die an sich schon sehr bestürzend sind, sich ständig wiederholen.
Genau die Mechanismen, die darum greifen, wiederholen sich extrem. Dadurch kam unser Ansatz in der Geschichte zustande. Was ich noch ganz wichtig finde, weil Gabriela gerade auch etwas dazu erzählt hat, wie die einzelnen Fälle gelagert sind, mit wem wir gesprochen haben, mit wem wir teilweise nicht sprechen konnten. Wir haben ja viele anonymisierte Geschichten. Ich finde es aber ganz wichtig, zu sagen, dass anonymen nicht bedeutet, dass wir von jemandem eine Geschichte erzählt bekommen und die dann aufschreiben, sondern dass wir uns ja klar waren, dass das eine heikle Geschichte ist und dass wir eben – das war ein Teil der Hauptarbeit – die Belege, also die Beleglage sehr, sehr gut sein mussten, damit wir diese Fälle mit einbeziehen können. So auch im Fall von Kascha Lenhardt haben wir jetzt nicht gesagt, sie kann nichts mehr sagen und wir schreiben das jetzt auf, wie wir das andere erklären, sondern alles, was wir aufgeschrieben haben, hat halt eine sehr, sehr gute Beleglage. Und das ist auch ein Teil, warum diese Recherche so komplex war und so lange gedauert hat, weil man natürlich das auch erstmal zusammenrecherchieren muss.
Wie lange wart ihr an der Recherche insgesamt jetzt gesessen?
Also ich habe seit Januar daran gearbeitet.
Also ich habe seit letztem Jahr schon so lose daran gearbeitet und dann jetzt seit einem halben Jahr sehr intensiv.
Da sieht man mal, was dahinter steckt. Weil jetzt der Name schon so oft gefallen ist und ich mir auch vorstellen könnte, dass vielleicht gar nicht jeder der Hörerinnen und Hörer weiß, was da mit Kasia Lenhardt und Jerome Boateng passiert. Das wollen wir vielleicht damit mal starten, könnte mal kurz erklären, was sind da die Dinge, die auch journalistisch relevant sind? Eigentlich geht uns ja das Privatleben von Menschen nicht an, aber in solchen Fällen dann natürlich eben schon.
Genau, Kasia Lenhardt ist die Ex-Freundin von Jerome Boateng. Das ist ja eine Geschichte, die auf Social Media schon sehr, oder eine Beziehung, die da sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit erregt hat, weil das irgendwie eine recht komplizierte Beziehungssituation gewesen sein muss. Tatsächlich relevant wurde diese Geschichte aber dann im letzten Jahr, als Jerome Boateng ihr offenbar ein NDA vorgelegt hat zum Unterschreiben, als die Beziehung anscheinend zu Ende ging.
Also eine Verschwiegenheitserklärung ist das. Das englische Wort Non-Disclosure Agreement.
Genau. Und dieser Vertrag war nur einseitig, galt also nur für sie. Sie hat damit unterschrieben, dass sie zu ihrer Beziehung und allem, was darin eine Rolle spielt, zu keinem Dritten mehr sprechen darf. Das heißt, niemandem, also nicht Familie, nicht Freunden, nicht vor Gericht, nicht zur Polizei, also einfach, genau. Und sie hat das unterschrieben. Und wenige Tage später hat Jerome Boateng ein Interview bei der Bildzeitung gegeben, das auch für sehr viel Aufsehen, also zu sehr viel Aufsehen erregt hat, weil er da einfach wahnsinnig heftige Vorwürfe und Behauptungen über Cascha Leinhardt ausgepackt hat. Und dieses Interview ist auch extrem umstritten. Da gab es auch schon eine Rüge vom Presserat. In diesem Interview wirft er ihr zum Beispiel vor, dass sie eine Alkoholikerin ist, dass sie ihn erpresst hat, dass sie ihn bedroht hat und dass er eigentlich gar nicht freiwillig in dieser Beziehung war. Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, dass dieses Interview, so wie es geführt wurde, so wie es da stand, sowieso auf allen Ebenen journalistisch fragwürdig ist. Hinzu kommt aber auch noch, dass sie wohl nach Aussage ihres Anwalts gar nicht angefragt wurde zu diesem Interview, was ja auch wieder einen wichtigen journalistischen Grundsatz einrennt. Und sie natürlich auch aufgrund dieses NDAs, den sie vorher unterzeichnet hatte, den Eindruck hatte, sich dazu nicht äußern zu können oder zu dürfen. Und das ist natürlich so eine Konstellation. Sie hatte dann auch wohl sehr große Angst davor, dass sie das Sorgerecht für ihren Sohn verlieren könnte. Das hat halt ihr Leben wohl sehr, sehr heftig beeinflusst. Ihr ganzes Umfeld, na ja, eigentlich die ganze Nation hatte plötzlich ein Bild von ihr, das, so wie ihr Anwalt auch es beschrieben hat, belegte Unwahrheiten oder belegbare Unwahrheiten sind, aber sehr persönlich über sie. Und das war natürlich ein riesiger Punkt. Und dann, wenige Tage später, hat sie offenbar Suizid begangen. Und das war dann das, wie dieser ganze Ablauf sehr, sehr viel besprochen wurde, und wie ich jetzt gerade schon zu Anfang sagte, aber unter einem ganz bestimmten Gesichtspunkt.
Also dieses Interview, was er da gegeben hat, das wirkt definitiv so wie das, was im Englischen unter Character Assassination läuft. Es war ein kompletter Rundumschlag gegen eine Ex-Freundin mit unbelegten Behauptungen, die sehr weit in ihr Intimleben gehen, in ihr Privatleben gehen, und sie als Person praktisch in Stücke reißt. Und dieses Interview hat eine große Hasslawine im Internet gegen sie losgetreten. Sie erhielt also eine Flut von Hassnachrichten und Beschimpfungen über Social Media. Das Ganze ist dann so als mahnendes Beispiel, wozu Hass im Netz führen kann, in der Presse besprochen worden. Aber uns hat eigentlich da interessiert, was eigentlich da der genaue Ablauf war. Und dieser Ablauf ist eben, dass Kascha Lenhardt nach allem, was wir jetzt ausgewertet haben, stellt sich dieser Eindruck ein, unter großem Druck und Bedrohung ein NDA unterzeichnet hat. Das heißt, selber sich juristisch zum Schweigen verpflichtete. Und in unmittelbarer zeitlicher Abfolge gibt ihr Ex-Freund der Fußball-Weltstar, der sowieso natürlich schon im Promi-Faktor drei Stufen oder fünf Stufen über ihr steht, in dem reichweitenstärksten Medium ein solches Interview. Da drängt sich schon auf, dass der Eindruck, dass da ein Kalkül hinter steckt.
Für mich wirkte das wie ein inszenierter Rufmord. Also da sollte jemand öffentlich diskreditiert werden und irgendwie die Kredibilität offenbar wirklich zerrissen werden. Daran lassen sich ja auch schon einige Strukturen festmachen. Also allein dieser Einsatz des NDAs, aber auch tatsächlich die Rolle der Medien. Also die Rolle der Bildzeitung und dieses Vorgehen, das ist auch etwas, was uns auf eine ähnliche Art wieder begegnet ist in anderen Fällen. Also dieser sehr enge Kontakt zwischen Profifußballerkontext und Boulevardmedien und darüber dann auch eine sehr kontrollierte Berichterstattung, die sehr einseitig ist, in der dann auch sozusagen die eine Seite andere Druckmittel hat, um bestimmte Geschichten unterzubringen und bestimmte Geschichten unter den Teppich fallen zu lassen, in der nur manche befragt werden und andere irgendwie überhaupt nicht wie relevante Personen oder echte Menschen wahrgenommen werden. Und also die Rolle der Bildzeitung ist da einfach extrem unrühmlich. Man muss auch dazu sagen, das Interview, das war jetzt noch bis September, auf der Website zu finden, obwohl es halt eben eine Rügens Presse Rat es gab. Und Jerome Boateng hat auch zu dem – also man muss ja auch sagen, nach diesem offenbaren Suizid – das wäre ja auch schon ein Moment gewesen, eigentlich sich als Bildzeitung einmal zu überlegen, ob man dieses Interview weiter bei sich auf der Seite hat und damit weiter Geld verdient. Offenbar hat sich darüber keiner Gedanken gemacht.
Wobei inzwischen habe ich schon fast den umgekehrten Eindruck, inzwischen durch auch durch unsere Berichterstattung ist dieses Interview jetzt eigentlich eher etwas, wo man ein fragwürdiges Verhalten von Boateng definitiv nachweisen kann. Und insofern ist das schon fast wieder ein Stück Realität, was da fehlt. Es ist natürlich gut für die Familie, dass es weg ist. Und es hat viele Dinge, wo man sagen würde, presserechtlich wäre das sowieso absolut angreifbar gewesen. Also wenn man sich ein bisschen mit Medienrecht auskennt, unbelegte Tatsachenbehauptungen, die eine Person extrem im öffentlichen Ansehen herabsetzen, sind einfach so nicht machbar. Vor allem nicht, wenn keine Gegenstellungnahme eingeholt worden sei. Und selbst wenn, kann man nicht einfach irgendwie so was Ehrverletzendes über eine Person öffentlich behaupten.
Und vor allem waren das eben auch Informationen, die die Intimsphäre von Kascha Lenhardt betroffen haben. Und da greift das Presserecht noch viel, viel stärker. Also es ist einfach unfassbar, dass das sich überhaupt abgespielt hat. Ich stimme Gabriela zu, dass eigentlich jetzt im Kontext dieser Recherche da jetzt auch wieder ein Dokument fehlt. Was ich aber ganz wichtig finde, ist, dass der neue Chefredakteur der Bildzeitung Johannes Boje sich jetzt erstmals auch distanziert hat von diesem Interview. Und das macht natürlich etwas mit den Betroffenen und auch den Hinterbliebenen, da einmal zumindest so eine kleine Geste des, weiß nicht, des Verantwortungsübernehmens in einem allerersten Schritt passiert. Und das passiert halt so selten in diesem Kontext, eigentlich fast nie.
Ja, und was halt auffällig ist, ist, dass mehrere der Frauen, mit denen wir sonst gesprochen haben, sind mit genau so etwas bedroht worden. Also ein Teil dessen, die Frauen unter Druck zu setzen, ist, dass die Männer denen gesagt haben, ich kann dich in den Medien zerstören, ich kann Gerüchte über dich verbreiten, ich bin mächtig, du bist es nicht, ich habe diese Mittel, du hast sie nicht, mir werden sie glauben, dir werden sie nicht glauben. Und das tatsächlich auch schon bevor das mit Kasha Lehnhardt passiert ist. Und da hat man jetzt tatsächlich einmal so ein Paradebeispiel, wie weit das gehen kann und wie verheerend sich das auswirken kann. Und hier am Ende ist die Frau halt tot, sie starb wenige Wochen, nachdem das Interview rauskam. Und das wirkt natürlich auch als ein anderes Beispiel.
Und auch dazu wieder, gab es keine Aufarbeitung, gab es irgendwie keine… Also das wäre ja auch sonst eigentlich… Also ich finde, da hätte ja auch eine Reaktion von den Strukturen selbst kommen können. Aber das Beispiel war ja groß genug und offensichtlich genug, aber auch da ist nichts passiert. Und ich fand das, was Gabriela gerade sagte, mit dem, dass es halt eben viele damit bedroht waren, dass aber auch irgendwie dieser Fall, Kascha-Lehn hat für viele, ja, anscheinend sich viele damit identifizieren konnten, die in ähnlichen Situationen waren, das ist ja erschreckend. Und da fand ich auch jetzt diese Szene bei dem Gerichtsprozess von Jerome Boateng jetzt bei dem Letzten, in dem es um vorsätzliche Körperverletzung ging, auch wieder sehr bezeichnend. Da gab es ja den Moment, in dem eine Zeugin, bei der vor Gericht sich nicht so richtig getraut hat, klar zu antworten auf die Fragen der Anwältin und dann auf Nachfrage in Tränen ausgebrochen ist und ausgesagt hat, dass sie vor der Gerichtsverhandlung gefilmt wurde von Männern, wo sich herausstellte, dass es die Bodyguards von Jérôme Boateng waren, und sie dann auch in diesem Moment sagte, dass sie wahnsinnige Angst hätte auch wegen dem, was Cascha-Lehnhardt passiert ist. Also da ist so diese, also das, was offenbar vielen, die in diesem Kontext sind, für möglich halten oder wovor sie Angst haben, da scheint dieser Fall Cascha-Lehnhardt beispielhaft zu sein. Und genau, das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel dafür. Und deswegen ist dieser Fall für uns auch in der Geschichte so relevant, weil das einfach so die Fallhöhe klarmacht.
Ja klar, stärker geht es nicht. Und ich würde ganz gerne auch, bevor wir dann über den Prozess, denke ich, sicher auch noch sprechen müssen bei Joe Rombo, ich würde gerne noch bei dem bleiben, was da passiert ist, rund um ihren offenbar Suizid, den sie begangen hat, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, sogar am 6. Geburtstag ihres Sohnes oder in unmittelbarer Nähe. Also ein ganz schreckliches Detail, was ich aber jetzt nur deshalb zitiere, um klarzumachen, das sind eigentlich die Geschichten, die immer ganz groß gefahren werden. Denn das geht dann jeden Menschen an, es berührt auch jeden Menschen. Mir selbst geht es jetzt auch gerade wieder so, wenn ich das wieder erzähle. Und dennoch war das Echo aus dem Fußball heraus bemerkenswert nicht existent. Also weder der FC Bayern musste sich zu seinem aktuellen Spieler, damals noch aktuellen Spieler, äußern, noch Jerome Boiteng. Also irgendwann, glaube ich, hatte er dann auf Instagram was gepostet. Aber da gab es eigentlich keinen Bezug zu sich selbst, hat er da hergestellt.
Ja, irgendwann lief er in dem zeitlichen Zusammenhang auch mal mit einer schwarzen Trauerbinde irgendwie auf dem Spielfeld herum. Aber keiner weiß, ob das jetzt mit Casualeina zu tun hatte oder mit irgendwas anderem.
Und er war da ja auch gerade in einem Trainingslager, von dem er dann angeblich nach Hause gereist ist. Ich habe jetzt auch wieder andersherum gehört, dass er wohl gar nicht nach Hause gereist sein soll. Und dann merkt man dann auch wieder, es geht dann ganz stark darum, irgendwie das Image dann direkt wieder zu schützen. In dem Fall hat man wohl den Eindruck, indem man einfach gar nichts dazu sagt, kann man das ganz gut schützen und es vor allem davon so abgrenzt. Dass es irgendwie alle anderen Gründe wurden bemüht, außer mal so ein bisschen auf die eigene Branche zu schauen und zu gucken, welche Strukturen von uns könnten eigentlich dazu beigetragen haben, eine Situation zum Eskalieren zu bringen. Und das ist doch irgendwie auch wieder sehr bezeichnend dafür. Und was ich eben auch interessant finde, ist, dass jetzt unsere Recherche veröffentlicht worden ist. Wir relativ oft so etwas gehört haben, wie dass Menschen aus der Branche jetzt gar nicht so wahnsinnig überrascht davon sind. Und es ja aber trotzdem, also sozusagen zu diesem strukturellen Punkt, noch nie eine Geschichte öffentlich geworden ist. Und wenn man sieht, wie tief diese Probleme gehen, ist das doch sehr schockierend. Und das spricht jetzt irgendwie nicht dafür, dass damit wahnsinnig konstruktiv umgegangen wird. Und jetzt auch noch immer ist es ja nicht so, dass wir mal vom DFB irgendeine Stellungnahme – wir haben ja auch wirklich mehrmals angefragt bei verschiedenen Vereinen beim DFB – da fehlt ja noch immer jegliche Stellungnahme und auch zum Beispiel so ein Ansatz, wie könnte man denn jetzt konstruktiv damit umgehen? Man könnte jetzt zum Beispiel auch mal überlegen, brauchen wir vielleicht bestimmte Strukturen, die helfen könnten? Was ist denn eigentlich das Prozedere, wenn so ein Fall aufkommt, also sich überhaupt erst mal damit auseinanderzusetzen und auch öffentlich dazu Stellung zu beziehen? Ehrlich gesagt, was auch immer das dann ist, irgendeine Form der Anerkennung dieses Themas und dass es etwas mit der eigenen Branche zu tun hat, wäre vielleicht ein erster Schritt und nicht mal mehr das passiert.
Ja, und weil wir da ja auch noch so ein zeitliches Zusammenfahren haben von eigentlich zwei getrennten Themen, aber es ist in den USA, das war eben das letzte Tribünengespräch, der sogenannte Yates Report rausgekommen, bei dem eben auch ein struktureller Missbrauch in psychischer und zum Teil auch sexueller Art an Spielerinnen in der Profiliga aufgedeckt wurde. In diesem Report stand auch da nochmal explizit drin. Also wir haben jetzt nur die Liga untersucht, wir gehen davon aus, in den Amateurlingen ist es noch viel schlimmer, denn auch da haben wir ganz viel gehört. Das heißt, wir haben sogar den Fall, dass Sportlerinnen betroffen werden. Und ich möchte das jetzt nicht miteinander, also dass das eine mehr wert, als das andere wäre. Aber das sind jetzt zwei Anlässe, wo eigentlich dann ein Verband vor allem sagen müsste, okay, was müssen wir denn tun, um eben Strukturen zu schaffen, dass eben dieses Kartell des Schweigens, das auferzwungen wurde, nicht so da ist. Und das ist schon erstaunlich. Und ich glaube, da gibt es so zwei Perspektiven. Das eine ist die Perspektive derjenigen, die einfach nichts sagen. Und das andere ist aber auch die Perspektive derjenigen, die nicht oft genug fragen, damit dieses Nichts-Sagen nicht auffällt. Also einmal die Verbände, die Vereine und so weiter. Und zum anderen dann die Medien. Was waren denn jetzt eure Erfahrungen, denn ihr wart ja jetzt quasi direkt beteiligt, rund um auch um eure Veröffentlichungen, mit diesen beiden Seiten und wie sie sich verhalten, wenn sowas aufgedeckt oder thematisiert wird?
Also wir haben tatsächlich in Folge der Veröffentlichung sehr viel Interesse zurückbekommen, auch von unterschiedlichsten Medien. Also das geht von Frauenmagazinen über den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk in mehreren Fällen, Deutschlandfunk, Privatfernsehen, also RTL und Sat1. Sie ist aufgegriffen worden in einem ganzen Strauß von Lokalzeitungen, in der Taz, in der Zeit. Also das Interesse ist riesig. Wir sind auch von verschiedenen Podcasts angefragt worden und haben jetzt ziemlich viel Zeit damit verbracht, auch Fragen dazu zu beantworten, was wir großartig finden, weil das eben zeigt, dass das Interesse daran eben sehr groß ist. Aber das Schweigen der Sportwelt fällt deutlich auf. Also Rasenfunk ist ein Sportpodcast und wir haben auch einen anderen Sportpodcast. Also die Podcasts, die jüngeren Formate, haben uns tatsächlich auch aufgegriffen. Aber so die großen Sportmedien, das fällt auf, tun so, als gäbe es das nicht. Da ist keiner auf die Idee gekommen, das aufzugreifen oder bei uns anzufragen. Und das ist natürlich schon auffällig.
Ich glaube, es ist jetzt nicht mal mehr nur so, dass da keiner drauf gekommen ist, sondern das, was uns auch in der Recherche immer mal wieder entgegengekommen ist, sind das, was ich eben beschrieben habe, diese Situation, dass die Sportredakteure auch sehr stark darauf angewiesen sind, an Informationen zu kommen. Weil das eben und gleichzeitig in Zeitungen der Sportteil noch mal ein sehr eigener Teil ist, der auch noch sehr gut funktioniert, viele Leser an sich bindet. Also es ist wirtschaftlich einfach ein wichtiger Teil. Und insofern zum Beispiel sowas wie die Transfer-News als erstes zu bekommen, ein riesen, riesen Wert und auch Druckmittel sind. Und da scheint es dann halt auch eben jetzt nicht so unüblich zu sein, dass wenn eine unangenehme Geschichte aufkommt, sich jemand aus dem Verein meldet und sagt hier die Geschichte, die hätten wir jetzt nun lieber nicht unbedingt. Wenn ihr weiter die Transfer-News als erstes haben wollt, dann ist es vielleicht besser, wenn die nicht erscheint. Wir hätten aber diese Geschichte, die könnte man ja dann vielleicht stattdessen machen. Und ich glaube, das ist schon sehr, sehr stark normalisiert in dieser – ich nenne es jetzt mal – Zusammenarbeit. Und das merken wir jetzt, indem unsere Geschichte aufgegriffen wird. Aber natürlich merkt man es auch in Bezug darauf, dass so eine Geschichte vorher niemals aufgekommen ist. Und das betrifft jetzt sozusagen die Medien. Ja, aber genauso eigentlich – uns ist ja gar nicht daran gelegen, jetzt eine einseitige Darstellung oder eine einseitige Berichterstattung zu machen. Wir hätten da sehr gerne mehr Austausch mit der Fußballwelt und würden da gerne diskutieren, wie die andere Seite das sieht. Wir haben da auch wirklich lange Fragenkataloge herum verschickt, aber sehr wenig Antworten und überhaupt sehr wenig Auseinandersetzungen zumindest mitbekommen. Ich gehe schon davon aus, dass das da diskutiert wird, aber nicht in der Öffentlichkeit. Und das ist doch recht bezeichnend. Und da kommt dann dieses Gefühl auf von, na ja, lass uns doch Fußball mal einfach wirklich nur auf dem Platz stattfinden lassen. Und da einigen sich dann irgendwie alle so unterm Strich drauf. Und dann gibt es vielleicht auch so die Hoffnung, dass dann so ein Ereignis wie die bevorstehende Weltmeisterschaft dann auch nochmal irgendwie das Thema so ein bisschen versanden lässt. Oder, weiß nicht, aber das sind jetzt nur Mutmaßungen. Aber es ist ja, es ist schon auffallend.
Na ja, der Sport oder der Fußball im Besonderen in Deutschland, der ist eben sehr lukrativ. Und deswegen gibt es, es gibt Abhängigkeitsverhältnisse. Also die gibt es ja überall. Das muss man jetzt nicht auch immer gleich problematisieren. Aber es gibt halt eine Abhängigkeit des Sportjournalismus vom Sport. Und gleichzeitig auch innerhalb der Verlage und der Zeitung gibt es auch eine Abhängigkeit vom Sportteil. Denn der ist so ein perpetuum mobile, das ist der kleinste Grimm-Meinsamer-Nenner, auf den sich ganz viele KonsumentInnen einigen können. Die interessieren sich alle für den Sportteil.
Und gleichzeitig kommt – Ganz kurz, also ich würde das schon grundsätzlich auch problematisieren, dass es da eine Abhängigkeit gibt, weil das natürlich immer ein Problem für die freie Presse ist, wenn man abhängig von einem bestimmten Sektor ist. Und die extreme Nähe von dem Berichterstattern und dem Berichterstattungs-Toujet, die ist ja auch nicht nur wirtschaftlich, die ist ja auch ideell. Man steht halt ständig gemeinsam am Spielfeld ran. Und die meisten Sportjournalisten werden ja Sportjournalisten, weil sie sich auch begeistern für den Fußball. Und das ist ja auch okay. Aber wenn es dann dazu führt, dass ich mich beeinflussen lasse, bestimmte unliebsame Neuigkeiten eben nicht zu machen, dann mache ich einfach auch meinen Job nicht richtig.
Dass da die journalistische Unabhängigkeit so flächendeckend offenbar verloren gegangen ist in dem Bereich, das ist ja ein massives strukturelles Problem. Vor allem, wenn wir sagen, dass eigentlich der freie Journalismus, die freie Presse schon ein Grundpfeiler unserer Demokratie, so dazu wie auch Missstände behoben werden können. Da sehen wir ja genau, wo das hinführt. Und tatsächlich diese Abhängigkeit von Informationsbeschaffung, das trifft ja auf jeden Teil des Journalismus zu. Also wir sind ja in allen Bereichen darauf angewiesen, Informationen zu bekommen. Und das geht auch mit einer kritischen Berichterstattung. Es ist nur offenbar im Bereich Fußball wird das irgendwie so nicht mehr ganz konsequent umgesetzt.
Ja, genau. Vielen Dank, dass du das präzisiert hast. Ich meinte quasi, ich wollte nicht allgemein Abhängigkeiten jetzt problematisieren. Aber das ist natürlich ein wichtiger Punkt. Da kommen dann eben auch noch so Details mit dazu. Wer hat Zugang zu spielen? Wer wird akkreditiert? Wer kommt ins Stadion? Da gibt es dann ein Hausrecht, was ausgeübt wird. Natürlich, wenn eine pressige Akkreditierung mal entzogen wird, dann ist das zum Glück auch unter Journalisten, Verbänden usw. ein Thema. Und da müssen dann die Vereine oft zurückrudern. Das hatten wir schon in einzelnen Fällen, dass eben einzelne Journalisten wegen ihrer Berichterstattung der Zugang verwehrt werden sollte. Und gleichzeitig – und das finde ich, ist aber glaube ich, noch mal ein zweiter Aspekt, auf den man kommen muss, und der auch erklärt, warum die Reaktion gerade von Frauen im Sportjournalismus war, dass sie gesagt haben, uns erschreckt das gar nicht. Und das wiederum ist ja in sich erschreckend, wenn man hier sehr explizite Vorwürfe liest. Und das soweit geht mit – das haben wir jetzt noch nicht erwähnt – aber dass da eine Frau, der mutmaßlich abgehört wurde von Jerome Boateng, eine Ex-Partnerin von ihm, mit einem Mikrofon im Schlafzimmer. Also, mich hat das erschreckt. Und wenn dann die Reaktion von Frauen ist, uns hat das gar nicht erschreckt, dann sagt das ja auch etwas aus über die Strukturen. Und das ist, glaube ich, das Zweite, dass hier Männern mit Männern oft sprechen.
Ganz kurz, wir wissen nicht, ob Jerome Boateng verantwortlich war für diese Wanze. Was wir wissen ist, es gab diese Wanze bei einer anderen Ex-Freundin von Jerome Boateng, die hat sie gefunden. Wir haben das auch dokumentiert. Uns liegen Fotos von dieser Wanze vor, aber es gibt keine Verbindung zu Boateng.
Was wir schon sagen können, ist, dass die Frauen vielleicht auch teilweise schon erschrocken waren, aber nicht überrascht. Und wir haben auch in unserer Recherche, dass nicht nur im Kontext von Jerome Boateng so eine Angst gehört, sondern auch von anderen Frauen, die den Eindruck hatten, dass sie abgehört werden, dass sie vielleicht auch damit bedroht wurden, abgehört zu werden, oder dass sie das Gefühl hatten, dass ihre Geräte gehackt wurden. Also das ist dann etwas, wo ich wiederum überrascht war, wie normalisiert das in diesem Milieu zu sein scheint.
Genau. Und wir haben eben diesen Fakt, dass der Sportjournalismus eine noch leider sehr frauenarme Branche ist. Glaubt ihr, dass das auch eine wichtige Rolle spielt? Weil es ist ja auffällig, wenn man den größeren Kontext aufmacht und eben sich die MeToo-Debatte in den USA anguckt und dann einfach mal guckt, was davon hat sich denn in Deutschland wiedergefunden mit deutschen Recherchen, dann ist es ja schon auffällig, dass es so gewisse Branchen gab, in denen kleinere, vermeintliche Einzelfälle hochgekommen sind, aber der große Aufschrei ist jetzt nicht zufällig gewählt. Also Hashtag Aufschrei war ja eine der Folgen von MeToo. Aber es ist ja interessant, dass wir das in Deutschland jetzt einfach mal ganz solopp gesagt so nicht hatten, dass es eben ein mannigfaltiges sich Öffnen und Aufdecken gab.
Also die MeToo-Debatte in Deutschland hing ja sowieso hinterher. Ich finde, genau das, was du gerade sagst, in den USA, wurde mit diesem Fall um Harvey Weinstein sehr stark aufgearbeitet. Es gibt einen riesigen Diskurs darum. Und in Deutschland haben wir ja auch diesen Fall irgendwie sehr, sehr stark begleitet und uns damit auseinandergesetzt, aber interessanterweise als amerikanisches Problem wahrgenommen. Also es wurde nie die Perspektive gedreht, um zu sagen, okay, und wie sieht es eigentlich bei uns aus? Und da muss man sagen, es ist jetzt kein fußballspezifisches Thema alleine. Da sind ja ganz viele Branchen betroffen von. Und es geht ja auch darum, dass wir gerade einen Paradigmenwechsel haben, in dem viele Dinge, die vielleicht vor 20 Jahren noch als normal und vollkommen unproblematisch angesehen wurden, wir jetzt anders sehen im Zuge einer ernst gemeinten Gleichberechtigung. Und da kommt es natürlich auch dazu, dass bestimmte Mechanismen überdacht werden müssen. Und das passiert in Deutschland nicht, habe ich den Eindruck. Also auf der Tonebene sind sich alle einig, dass wir eine gleichberechtigte Gesellschaft wollen und haben. Aber in den Mechanismen und Strukturen und dann Verhaltensweisen, da wird es wenig angesprochen und wenig kritisch angeschaut. Und das trifft auf die Welt des Fußballs natürlich extrem auch zu, weil das ja auch eine sehr archaische Welt noch ist. Es ist fast so ein bisschen wie ein Rückzugsort patriarchaler Werte. Und das wird auch sehr stark beschützt, habe ich den Eindruck. Und darin hat das natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere Wucht. Dennoch würde ich sagen, dass sich da auch andere Branchen mal ganz selbstkritisch anschauen müssen. Ich gehe auch nicht davon aus, dass das die letzte Geschichte war.
Nee, also ich stimme zu, dass das jetzt nicht per se und alleine ein Fußballproblem ist, natürlich nicht. Und wir wollen auch, das ist glaube ich auch nochmal wichtig zu sagen, jetzt mit der Recherche nicht suggerieren, dass Fußballer überproportional häufig häusliche Gewalt ausüben. Da haben wir keine Belege für. Wir haben am Anfang gesagt, dass wir neun Fälle hatten, was für uns schon ein totaler riesiger Erfolg war, weil es eben so schwer ist, an diese Frauen ranzukommen. Da sind neun Fälle schon echt eine ganze Menge. Aber es ist natürlich verschwindend wenig, um jetzt Aussagen über die ganze Fußballbranche zu treffen und wie verbreitet die Probleme da sind. Darum ging es uns überhaupt nicht, sondern es ging uns darum, dass wir bestimmte Muster aufdecken und aufzeigen, welche Schwierigkeiten die Frauen eben haben oder wie stark sie in die Hilflosigkeit getrieben werden durch dieses – wie es die Süddeutsche genannt hat – organisierte Schweigen. Andererseits ist es natürlich schon so, dass wir da einige Besonderheiten haben, die den Frauen auf die Füße fallen. Dazu gehört natürlich, dass das eine total Männer dominierte Branche ist, wo auch Regeln gelten, die anderswo schon ganz lange nicht mehr gelten. Also es ist ja zum Beispiel auch so, dass homosexuelle Fußballspieler nach wie vor eine unvorstellbare Sache sind. Das ist krass, wenn wir überlegen, in welchem Jahrhundert und welchem Jahr wir uns bewegen.
Also wenn man da jetzt mal allein statistisch draufschaut, kann man sich ausrechnen, wie viele Fälle von – ich nenne es mal – unterdrückten Identität oder zumindest öffentlich nicht dargestellten Identitätssituation es da gibt. Und ich finde, das ist tatsächlich ganz wichtig auch im Bezug darauf, dass du eben sagtest, mit dem das Fußfall dann oft auch so der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner der Nation irgendwie ist, dass das eine Welt ist, die jetzt nicht nur in sich so funktioniert, sondern so viele Menschen begeistern sich ja für eben genau diese Welt. Und deswegen ist das ja auch so ein dankbarer Marketingmagnet. Und dass aber eben diese Werte so recht unhinterfragt da drin existieren und auch gar nicht konterkariert werden. Also das ist doch, also allein auch die Frauenbilder, die da vorherrschen, das wieder, wie dann auch Frauen wieder medial, also zum Beispiel eben die Partnerinnen von Fußballern, wie die überhaupt medial dargestellt werden, die werden komplett als Objekte, das sind Objekte, über die man reden darf, vor allem gerne über das Aussehen, die aber selber nicht gefragt werden, die auch vor allem keine eigenständige Meinung haben dürfen. Ist ja auch schon so, wenn irgendwie eine Partnerin, dass sich eine Partnerin mal über das Spiel eines Profifußballers äußert. Ich weiß gar nicht, kommt das jemals vor?
Es gab mal einen sehr bekannten Fall. Die Frau von Thomas Müller hat mal bei der Einwechslung von Thomas Müller gepostet. Endlich kommt Niko Kovac mal auf eine gute Idee. Und das war damals dann ein riesiges Thema. Aber ehrlicherweise glaube ich, dass das nicht ein riesiges Thema war, weil das eine Frau war, die das geäußert hat, sondern weil das damals perfekt in das Narrativ der vieler Sportjournalistinnen hineingepasst hat. Beziehungsweise, wahrscheinlich kann ich das Gendern da weglassen, weil eben Niko Kovac damals schon sehr umstritten war. Und dann wurde das sehr bereitwillig aufgestampft. Aber ansonsten ist es natürlich so, es fängt ja auch schon ein bisschen mit dem Wort Spielervrauen an. Und da habe ich zum Beispiel vor der Sendung auch viel darüber nachgedacht, denn eigentlich mag ich an dieser Bezeichnung nicht, dass man den Frauen ihre Identität quasi an den Spieler koppelt und das auch so voranstellt. Gleichzeitig gibt es leider kein Äquivalent und nur so wissen dann Menschen, über welche Frauen wir sprechen. Deswegen werdet ihr wahrscheinlich ähnliche Diskussionen gehabt haben.
Man muss natürlich dazu sagen, das gehört auch zur Wahrheit und das erklärt auch diese Abhängigkeitsverhältnisse, die sich hinterher eben als so verheerend rausstellen, dass die Frauen – das trifft nicht auf alle zu, aber es trifft auf einige zu, die natürlich auch angezogen sind von der Prominenz, von dem Glamour, von dem Star-Status, das ist ganz normal, das hat man ja auch in anderen Branchen. Was hier besonders reinkommt, ist, dass die Frauen – also zumindest in den Fällen, die mir jetzt spontan einfallen – ganz, ganz selten eigene starke Karrieren haben, die unabhängig von dem Mann funktionieren. Das heißt, wir haben hier noch diese klassische Versorgerehe, die ja auch in weiten Teilen Deutschlands nicht mehr Realität ist, und wo die Frauen natürlich auch erstmal große Vorteile davon haben und das wahrscheinlich auch auf Instagram entsprechend inszenieren. Und dadurch kommt – daraus speist sich so dieses Narrativ, dass das so diese Glitzer-Mädels sind, die halt auf den Luxus aus sind, die sich damit auch brüsten, die deswegen Instagram-Follower bekommen. Und man muss aber auch dazu sagen, dass die Frauen da – denen wird ja auch suggeriert, das war in mehreren Fällen so, die ich begleitet habe, denen wird suggeriert, dass sie finanziell safe sind, dass sie abgesichert sind, dass sie sich nicht kümmern brauchen, dass sie ja auch eigentlich gar keine Zeit haben, sich um eine eigene Karriere zu kümmern, eben weil der Mann so einen engen Profi-Fußballer-Terminplan hat.
Und die sind ja auch sehr stark eingebunden, also mit in diese ganze Marketing-Maschinerie rund um die Spiele herum. Also die müssen ja, also das heißt, die müssen aber dieser Teil, dass die Partnerinnen dann auf der Tribüne sitzen, dass die bei den Trainings dabei sind, die sollen dann auch Interviews geben, aber halt nur genau in dem Rahmen, der für sie vorgesehen ist. Und zwar immer als eben Spielerfrau, Frau des Spielers. Und was auch noch hinzukommt, genau das, was Gabriela gerade sagte, die Tatsache, dass viele da eine Karriere haben, die sich dann irgendwie so da drum herumfügt. Das liegt zum einen darin, dass das halt auch, so wie mir das gespiegelt wurde, sehr fordernd ist und den Alltag schon auch sehr mitbestimmt, dass eben der Alltag der Frauen sich dann auch eben um die Karriere des Mannes drehen muss. Aber oft ist es auch so, dass die einfach sehr, sehr jung zusammenkommen. Also es sind ja oft wahnsinnig junge Frauen, die in so eine Beziehung kommen und dann erstmal eigentlich als Privatperson und dann aber auf Strukturen treffen, die – und sag ich mal – wie so einen Raum für sie in dieser ganzen Welt, der sehr eng abgesteckt ist und dann vielleicht auch eine bestimmte Entwicklung dann ausbleibt, weil man sich da so einfügt. Und das bedingt dann natürlich auch noch eine große Abhängigkeit, aber dann auch die Darstellung im Ideal oder auch die Wahrnehmung gesellschaftlich dieser Frauen ist dann halt eben oft diese ganz oberflächliche und auch – also denen wird schon jegliche Kompetenz eigentlich abgesprochen. Und das ist halt – und das bedingt sich dann alles so gegenseitig. Und dadurch hat, glaube ich – ich glaube, dass das auch schon etwas damit zu tun hatte, wie wenig dann diese Geschichten ernst genommen wurden. Weil halt eben diese Menschen überhaupt nicht mehr ernst genommen wurden und damit auch nicht das, was ihnen zugestoßen ist. Und das ist doch – also – ja, und ich finde, das muss sich ändern. Also es muss sich ändern mit was für einer Ernsthaftigkeit. Also dass es da nicht so eine Verschiebung gibt von – na, das nehmen wir ganz wahnsinnig ernst, wenn ein Mann einen Ball in ein Tor schießt. Aber wenn es da jetzt irgendwie eine – und das kann man sehr ernst nehmen. Ich verstehe das total, dass es sportlich interessant ist und dass diese ganze Welt da eine Begeisterung für hat. Aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass Menschen, die auch Teil dieser Welt sind, das sind ja keine Feinde oder Angreifer. Die sind auch Teil dieser Welt, die lieben auch diesen Sport oder sind vielleicht auch begeistert davon. Aber dass die dann soweit nicht ernst genommen werden, dass wenn strafrechtlich relevante Dinge ihnen gegenüber passieren, alle wegschauen, es wegignoriert wird und niemand den Eindruck hat, dass da vielleicht etwas passieren muss. Das muss sich doch ändern.
Ja, ich wollte noch hinzufügen, also ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass die MeToo-Bewegung auch in Deutschland, also es gab schon auch viele Bereiche, die da unter die Lupe kamen. Also wir hatten Dieter Wedel, wir hatten mehrere Vorfälle im Kultursektor, wir hatten neulich erst wieder diesen Galeristen. Es hat tatsächlich eine ganze Reihe von Fällen gegeben, aber es sind auch immer wieder Bereiche unter die Lupe genommen worden. Aber diese Frauen, die sind völlig außerhalb der Wahrnehmung. Denn die Medien, die sich kümmern um strukturalisierte und geschlechterspezifische Gewalt und Sexismus, die gucken eben nicht auf Spielerfrauen. Die sind unsichtbar für die Qualitätsmedien, weil die von vornherein gelten als diese Spielerfrauen und Blink-Blink-Instagram-Promis, die halt eben eher etwas für die Boulevard-Berichterstattung sind. Und das, muss man auch dazu sagen, ist uns auch während der Recherche mehrfach gesagt worden. Wieso macht ihr das? Das ist doch ein Boulevard-Thema. Und wenn diese Frauen Kernphysikerinnen wären, würde niemand sagen, das ist ein Boulevard-Thema.
Und es ist dann in dem Sinne halt auch ein Klassenproblem, ne? Also, dass es dann so eine Klassifizierung gibt. Und das finde ich einfach immer noch unglaublich.
Ja, das ist krass. Und gleichzeitig, glaube ich, greift da noch ein Mechanismus, den man auch bei den Spielern selbst beobachten kann. Wenn jemand viel Geld mit etwas verdient, das er tut, dann kommt immer mal wieder, also kommt für die Millionen, die er hat, da soll er sich nicht so haben, soll er halt seinen Knie kaputt machen, seine Karriere beenden. Natürlich sind uns Gehirnerschütterungen egal, weil die kriegen ja ganz viel dafür. Und ich glaube, so ein bisschen strahlt das auch dann auf diesen Bereich der Partnerinnen ab, dass man sagt, ja Mensch, die leben doch, was leben die für ein Leben? Die haben doch so ein tolles Haus, jetzt sollen sie sich doch nicht haben. Und das ist natürlich eine ganz perfide und ja auch in sich eigentlich falsche Argumentation. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass das oft noch mal hinter dem Nicht-Beachten steckt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das sind auch Sätze, die wir irgendwie gefunden haben in den Geschichten dieser Frauen.
Und ich finde, du hast da völlig recht mit. Und ich finde, diese Übertragung, die du da vom Profifußballer und dem, was sozusagen ja auch da gefordert und normalisiert wird, dann in diese Beziehung, die Spielerfrauen, da hast du völlig recht mit. Ich glaube, dass da auch, also dass diese Sportwelt so sehr darauf beharrt, eigene Regeln zu haben, die dann teilweise auch eigentlich über den, ja fast schon der Eindruck entsteht, dass die über den Gesetzen stehen. Das ist ja auch spannend, also zum Beispiel, also das ist vielleicht ein komisches Gedankenspiel, aber wenn auf dem Platz es ein Faul gibt, was tatsächlich eigentlich auch, sag ich mal, außerhalb dieses Platzes vielleicht ein körperlicher Angriff wäre, wird das jemals vor einem Gericht eigentlich mal relevant. Also ja, naja, wenn es dann letztlich ein Fall von Körperverletzung auf dem Platz ist, dann ist das, was relevant ist, die rote Karte. Und damit ist das dann für den Sport geklärt. Also ich finde schon deswegen deine Übertragung interessant und richtig und wichtig, dass das vielleicht dann auch noch eine Rolle spielt in Bezug darauf, wie das Verhalten dann auch prägt von Sportlern.
Ja und gleichzeitig wird dann selbst in den naheliegendsten Fällen eins und eins nicht zusammengezählt. Und da kommen wir dann wahrscheinlich wieder zurück zu dem, was wir vorhin zu Sportjournalismus im Generellen gesagt haben. Also Jérôme Boateng ist dann später zum Beispiel zu Olympique Lyon gewechselt und da hat er sich eine heftige verbale Auseinandersetzung mit einem jungen Spieler geleistet, bei der er – ich sage mal zurückhaltend – zumindest ein aufbrausendes Temperament gezeigt hat. Und jetzt haben wir eben jemanden, gegen den tatsächlich ein Verfahren lief und jetzt ja aktuell auch gerade eine Verhandlung läuft, die eben genau mit solchen emotionalen Ausbrücken dann eben auch gewalttätigen Ausbrüchen zu tun hat. Und dann würde man meinen, das muss doch eigentlich eine große Meldung sein, weil es offenbart ja offenbar, dass da etwas noch liegt. Und dann guckt man und sieht das. Also es wurde ganz ganz vereinzelt in deutschen Medien zitiert, aber in keinem großen Medium irgendwie größer gefahren. Ich möchte jetzt auch gar nicht nur auf dieses eine Detail sehen, weil da gab es dann vielleicht dann wieder irgendwelche berichterstattenden Gründe, die ich nicht einsehen kann als kleiner Podcaster. Aber das ist eben so ein typischer Fall von, na wir wollen uns damit auch nicht auseinandersetzen, wir machen ja nur Sport. Und wenn wir aber auf der einen Seite sagen, der Fußball ist wichtig und der Fußball hat auch eine gesellschaftliche Relevanz, und das sagen ja übrigens diese Sportjournalisten auch alle, also die sind ja alle stolz, Sportjournalismus zu machen, dann muss man aber halt auch die Konsequenz daraus ziehen und sagen, na dann müssen wir aber gerade im Fußball auf Missstände hinweisen, denn das ist eben auch ein Feld, an dem man etwas sehr gut erzählen kann, weil eben sich alle dafür interessieren. Und darin liegt ja auch die große Kraft, glaube ich, eurer Recherche und vielleicht auch die Chance von zukünftigen Recherchen im Fußball, dadurch, dass sich dann doch eben so viele Menschen dafür interessieren und es eben nicht – in Anführungszeichen – nur der Theaterbetrieb ist. Das tut mir jetzt wahnsinnig leid, aber es interessieren sich halt leider weniger Menschen für Theater als für Fußball, kann man eben auch, glaube ich, mit diesen Geschichten noch mehr bewirken, weil sie auch Frauen erreichen, die vielleicht betroffen sind und weil sie sicherlich auch hoffentlich Journalistinnen und Journalisten zum Nachdenken bringen. Und deswegen würde ich ganz gerne auch nochmal, weil wir jetzt bisher nur über Jérôme Boateng und Cassia Lénard gesprochen haben, könnt ihr noch ein bisschen was sagen zu den anderen Fällen, die ihr recherchiert habt. Also ihr schreibt in einem Text, die Vorwürfe betreffen sechs ehemalige Nationalspieler, ein Bundesligaspieler, zwei sind oder waren im Kader in einer Mannschaft, in einer der höchsten Spielklassen in Europa. Also das ist quasi die Art der Partner, die es da gibt. Was ist euch da alles über den Weg gelaufen, salopp gesagt?
Also ich hatte es zu tun mit ganz unterschiedlichen Arten, eigentlich jeglichen Arten von Gewalt. Also es ging um, wie gesagt, Angriffe, körperliche Übergriffe, Schlagen, Schubsen, Treten, Würgen. Es ging um in einem Fall auch erhebliche Gewalt gegen die Kinder, also die gemeinsamen Kinder. Es gab Bedrohungen, teilweise auch bis weit über die Trennung hinaus, bis in jüngste Zeit. Drohungen von bis hin zu Todesdrohungen. Es gab, was auch immer wieder kommt und was ein bisschen schwieriger zu erklären ist, ist das, was unter wirtschaftliche Gewalt läuft, dass eben die wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit der Frauen ausgenutzt wird, um sie unter Druck zu setzen. Ich hatte mehrere Fälle, wo die Frauen nach langen, langen Ehen mit Kindern vor die Tür gesetzt wurden, von jetzt auf gleich, Kreditkarten gesperrt wurden, Konten gesperrt wurden. Ich glaube, das ist eben auch so das, wo die Bevölkerung oder die Öffentlichkeit sich eine falsche Vorstellung macht, weil die eben auf Instagram immer so aussehen, als würden sie nur im Luxus leben. Die sind ohne diese Männer tatsächlich – also ich hatte eine Frau, die wirklich mittellos ist, die nur von dem lebt, was ihre Familie ihr zuwendet. Und das taucht auch in den Geschichten, wo es um körperliche Gewalt geht, auf, dass den Frauen gesagt wird, also die werden dann sozusagen bestraft, indem man ihre Bezüge kürzt, indem man den Unterhalt für die Kinder kürzt, indem Zahlungen ausgesetzt werden, indem man sie praktisch dann dazu zwingt, sich Anwälte zu nehmen und um ihren Lebensunterhalt dann praktisch, dass sie den einklagen müssen, mehrfach, immer wieder, immer wieder verfahren. Diese Überwachungsdimension ist sehr stark. Also das hat damit zu tun, was ich wahrgenommen habe, dieses System der Kontrolle spiegelt sich immer wieder. Es ist von Abhörern die Rede, es ist von Hacking die Rede, es ist von Ausspähen die Rede. Was auch in den Zusammenhang passt, ich hatte mehrere Fälle, wo die Männer die Frauen ins Badezimmer eingesperrt haben, also stundenlang, was irgendwie so eine Art von Gewaltausübung ist, die ich vorher gar nicht so kannte. Das habe ich dann gleich von mehreren Frauen gehört, die zum Beispiel dann von den Männern ins Bad eingesperrt wurden mit der Aussage, ich muss jetzt spielen gehen oder trainieren gehen, ich kann mich nicht konzentrieren, wenn du in der Welt da draußen rumläufst und Gott weiß was machst.
Das ist ja einfach, also das ist ja Freiheitsberaubung. Das wird aber dann auch so marginalisiert. Es wird auch so normalisiert oder nicht mehr richtig wahrgenommen als. In der Tragweite, die es ja hat. Und genau das, was Gabriela gerade sagte, dass diese wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit so sehr ausgenutzt wird. Und es ist auch immer wieder begegnet, dass dann auch so Aussagen kamen, wie wenn jetzt zum Beispiel eine Frau sich hilfesuchend an einen Berater gewandt hat, dass immer so suggeriert wurde, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel zur Polizei gehst oder wenn du jetzt zu den Medien gehen würdest, dann schadest du der Karriere des Profifußballers und um die Ecke stammt. Damit schadest du ja dann auch dir. Und das kann ja nicht im Interesse von irgendwem sein. Und auch diese Täter-Opfer-Umkehr von du schadest ihm, wenn er sagen muss, das Problem ist ja nicht, dass jemand darüber spricht. Das Problem ist, dass das passiert ist. Aber das sieht überhaupt niemand mehr so. Da gibt es sozusagen diese Trennung von eigentlich ist die Verantwortlichkeit, setzt da ein, wo es sozusagen von jemandem zu einem Thema gemacht wird. Und wenn alle gesagt haben, wir wollen nicht, dass das ein Thema ist, dann übertritt derjenige sozusagen Regeln und nicht derjenige, der vorher irgendwie jemanden im Bad eingeschlossen hat oder geschlagen hat oder eingeschüchtert hat oder erpresst hat. Und das ist ja, ja, genau. Und das sind jetzt natürlich sozusagen die Fälle, die sehr extrem sind, die in Richtung häusliche Gewalt gehen. Es gibt also aber ja auch Fälle, die anders ablaufen. Also jetzt der Fall von Julia Meyer zum Beispiel, den wir beschrieben haben.
Also das ist ein anonymisierter Name.
Genau, ein anonymisierter Name, Entschuldigung. Und da ging es ja um eine Beziehung, die während der mehrjährigen Beziehung als sehr harmonisch wahrgenommen wurde, sehr, sehr positiv. Und dann erst, als es zur Trennung kam, dass dann plötzlich so professionalisiert wurde, Berater, Manager offenbar eingegriffen haben und dann die komplette Kommunikation so geleitet wurde, so dass das Image des Spielers komplett geschützt wurde und dafür auch gezielt Gerüchte gestreut wurden, dass sie auch unter Druck gesetzt wurde, sie musste auch ein NDA unterschreiben, dass dann plötzlich auch sozusagen, wo man sagen muss, es war einfach nur das Ende einer Beziehung. Das haben wir ja auch ein Zitat von Kasha Lenhardt aus einem Gespräch, wo sie sagt, sie versteht nicht, es hätte sich doch einfach getrennt werden können. Warum konnte man nicht einfach nur sagen, ich war nicht mehr glücklich mit ihr, ich habe sie nicht mehr geliebt? Und insofern trifft das auch auf diesen Julia-Meyer-Fall zu, wo man so denken würde, normalerweise könnte man sich einfach trennen, egal, wie relevant kann das sein, zu sagen, wir müssen hier jetzt sozusagen sie zum Schweigen bringen mit allen Mitteln, die wir haben, nur weil eine Beziehung endet und vielleicht auch nicht unter Umständen ganz sauber geendet hat. Aber das hat sich da abgespielt und da versteht man, finde ich, dann sozusagen, wie weit das greift, dass es jetzt nicht nur darum geht, wirklich strafrechtlich relevante Dinge zu vertuschen. Und ich meine jetzt nicht nur im Sinne von, das ist eine Kleinigkeit, sondern dass schon die Probleme, die nicht auftreten dürfen in dieser Fußballwelt rund um das Image dieser Spieler, weil das eben so wertvoll ist und so viele daran verdienen, dass das bei Kleinigkeiten anfängt, wie eben einfach einer Trennung.
Welche Rolle spielt denn dabei vielleicht? Also wir haben das vorhin schon mal so kurz gestreift, aber ich glaube, das lohnt noch mal einen genaueren Blick diese archaischen, patriarchalischen Strukturen des Fußballs. Also wenn du eben gerade sagst, Maike, man könnte sich ja in Anführungszeichen einfach nur trennen, dann würde ich als Antwort vermuten, naja, da geht es wahrscheinlich um Egos, da geht es sicherlich auch um einen Markenwert, den jeder Spieler selbst hat. Spielt das da auch noch mit rein, eure Erfahrung nach den Gesprächen, die ihr mit betroffenen Frauen hatten, dass es eben auch eine sehr männliche und sehr, ja, umstärke bemühte Außendarstellung ist, die wir da im Fußball haben?
Also das sind auf jeden Fall, geht es da um Werte. Ich hatte jetzt gar nicht den Eindruck, dass es so stark um die Egos geht oder die Egos zu schützen dieser Spieler, sondern diese traditionellen, sehr rückwärtsgewandten Werte von dem, wie Beziehungen zu sein haben. Tatsächlich eher das. Also zum Beispiel sich dann ja auch teilweise wahnsinnig viele Affären herausstellen, die dann aber, also die irgendwie es gegeben haben soll auf Seite des Profifußballers, wo man jetzt sagen würde, ja okay, dann war das einfach keine gute Beziehung. Aber das darf nicht stattfinden, weil halt eben auch inzwischen Profifußballer nicht mehr nur einfach sehr gute Sportler sind, sondern die sind ja seit ein paar Jahren wirklich zu Nationalhelden geworden und die müssen plötzlich für ganz, ganz vieles stehen, was vielleicht dann auch einfach ganz schwer zu erfüllen ist. Auch da gibt es ja einen ganz engen Rahmen von dem, was möglich ist. Und ich glaube, dadurch gibt es so diese Front, die halt diese traditionellen Familienwerte so fordert. Da spielt ja auch das rein, was Gabriela eben ansprach, dass Homosexualität da keine Rolle spielen darf. Das geht ja in alle möglichen Ecken. Und da fängt es dann schon an, dass es wichtig ist, dass diese Werte, weil die ja eben auch vermarktet werden, dass die nicht angegriffen werden dürfen durch irgendwelche Geschichten, die rauskommen. Und dann gibt es die Front, von dem was kommuniziert werden darf. Und dann aber darf dahinter sich ganz vieles abspielen. Man darf nur nicht darüber sprechen und es darf nicht öffentlich bekannt werden.
Das ist schon ein sehr perfides System, in dem ja gleichzeitig diese Verschwiegenheitserklärung, die NDAs eine sehr große Rolle spielen. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen aus den USA übernommen. Also durch den Harvey Weinstein-Fall unter anderem wissen wir, dass das dort eine sehr große Rolle spielt. Jetzt ist aber das Interessante daran, Juristinnen und Juristen sind sich gar nicht so einig, ob das eigentlich auch im Bereich des Privatlebens so gültig wäre. Denn das kommt ursprünglich so aus dem Unternehmensbereich. Geschäftsgeheimnisse dürfen nicht verraten werden, wenn man zu einem anderen Unternehmen geht und so weiter und so fort. Könnt ihr dazu noch ein, zwei Worte sagen? Denn man kann ja nie ausschließen, dass das hier vielleicht auch jemand hört, der selbst davon betroffen ist und dem das vielleicht so noch gar nicht klar war.
Ja, also es ist so, dass Verschwiegenheitsverpflichtungen im Privatleben juristisch stark umstritten sind. Also man kann davon ausgehen, da sind sich alle Juristen einig, dass bei einem Vorwurf von Gewalt oder Machtmissbrauch, Psychoterror, es würde keinen Richter geben, der sagen würde, ich erkläre jetzt in dem Fall, ich bewerte einen NDA für rechtmäßig und die Frau muss sich daran halten. Also da gibt es ja eine klare Güterabwägung. Und wenn es so ist, dass ein starkes wirtschaftliches Ungleichgewicht der Hintergrund ist, dann sagen Juristen, dass ein solcher NDA sehr leicht sitenwidrig und damit rechtswidrig sein kann. Und wenn es so ist, wie im Fall von Kascha Lenhardt, dass ein NDA nur eine Seite zum Schweigen verpflichtet, dann kann er mit Sicherheit rechtswidrig eingestuft werden.
Aber wir sehen, dass die trotzdem wahnsinnig effektiv sind. Und das ist das Perfide daran. Im Fall von Kascha Lenhardt sehen wir auch, sie hat einen wahnsinnigen Druck. Sie hatte eine Geschichte, die sie hätte richtig stellen wollen. Es ging auch darum, dass sie eigentlich Anzeige erstatten wollen wegen diesen offenbaren Angriffen von ihm. Sie hatte aber den Eindruck, dass sie das nicht kann, weil sie dachte, wenn man so einen Vertrag unterschreibt, geht man schon erstmal davon aus, dass das auch bindend ist. Dann müsste man sich erstmal von einem Rechtsanwalt beraten lassen. Diese Beratungen sind ja auch teuer und aufwendig. Und überhaupt erst einmal an den Punkt zu kommen, zu hinterfragen, ob das hinterfragbar ist, soweit kommen viele gar nicht.
Ja, und es ist tatsächlich auch nicht so ganz einfach. Wir haben auch die NDAs angucken lassen von Expertinnen und Experten. Und zu sagen, dieser NDA ist rechtswidrig, das ist nicht so leicht, weil so eine Vertragsprüfung tatsächlich aufwendig ist. Und wenn ein Anwalt das so bewertet, kann er hinterher auch theoretisch in Regress genommen werden, wenn es sich dann doch anders herausstellt. Das ist auch für die Anwälte ein Risiko. Vertragsrecht ist kompliziert. Also die Angst davor ist sicherlich größer als die juristische Wirkung. Weil man kann ja auch fragen, was passiert denn, wenn sie dagegen verstoßen? Also was soll da passieren? Natürlich können sie erst mal wieder zivilrechtlich verklagt werden. Und wenn eine Vertragsstrafe festgelegt ist, dann kann diese Vertragsstrafe natürlich fällig werden. Aber in mehreren NDAs, die wir gesehen haben, sind auch keine Vertragsstrafen vorgesehen. Andererseits sind sie natürlich häufig Teil von Trennungsverträgen, sodass die wirtschaftliche Grundlage der Frau, die Unterhaltszahlungen für die Kinder gekoppelt sind, an die Schweigeklausel. Und dann ist es natürlich schon irgendwie eine schwierige Sache, weil sich die Frage auftut, ob der Mann dann den ganzen Vertrag aufkündigen kann, wenn die andere Seite gegen eine dieser Klauseln theoretisch verstößt. Und wenn auch nicht festgelegt ist, wo diese Frau sich äußern darf, darf sie sich überhaupt in ihrem eigenen privaten Umfeld äußern, darf sie sich vor Behörden äußern, darf sie sich vor Gericht äußern. Also es gibt NDAs, die da ziemlich klar sind und sagen, vor Gericht hat er jetzt keine Gültigkeit, aber das ist längst nicht in allen Fällen der Fall. Du merkst ja jetzt, wie wir uns abmühen, die rechtliche Gültigkeit dieser NDAs einzuschätzen. Und das ist für jemanden, der so etwas unterschrieben hat, natürlich ein sehr großer Unsicherheitsfaktor. Und es ist ja auch so, dass diese NDAs nicht im luftleeren Raum hängen. Das sind alles Fälle, wo Frauen sowieso schon zu spüren bekommen haben, wie groß das Machtgefälle ist, die sowieso schon eingeschüchtert wurden, die sowieso schon etliche juristische Verfahren mit diesen Männern haben, die sowieso schon die Erfahrung gemacht haben, dass sie eben besser nicht versuchen sollen, sich zu versuchen, gegen sowas zu behaupten.
Ich glaube auch, dass genau diese Unklarheit, die auf verschiedenen Ebenen in Bezug auf diese NDAs herrscht, auch ein Grund ist, warum die so gut wirken. Weil eben zum Beispiel auch gerade, wenn die so sehr diffus formuliert sind, dann schließen die ja so alles und nichts ein. Und dann ist es sehr, sehr schwer abzuschätzen, was die Konsequenzen sind, aber auch, was ich überhaupt darf und was ich nicht darf. Den Frauen ist aber bewusst, dass es eben dieses Machtgefälle gibt und es für sie sehr problematisch ist, wenn sie bestimmte Grenzen übertreten. Und viele Juristen, mit denen wir gesprochen haben, fordern ja auch jetzt einfach sozusagen auf einer anderen Ebene in Bezug auf die NDAs, dass da in Deutschland mehr Klarheit rechtlich geschaffen wird. Also weil das halt tatsächlich so ist, dass ja, meistens würden die vor Gericht nicht standhalten, aber man kann schon auch erstmal verklagt werden und dann muss man halt so einen Prozess erstmal führen und dann muss man erstmal die finanziellen Mittel aufbringen. Und da ist ja dann auch immer die Frage, wer hat da den längeren Atem und wer hat da auch vor allem finanziell gesehen, mehr Möglichkeiten so etwas dann durchzuziehen und durchzusetzen. Und ja genau, in den USA wird ja gerade diskutiert, ob die ganz generell verboten werden sollen, die NDAs in Bezug auf private Beziehungen, weil da ja auch angeführt wird, dass das eben ganz stark ein Problem ist bei Missbrauchsfällen und weil da halt eben dieses Muster erkannt wurde, dass das oft dazu führt, dass eben keine Aussagen getroffen werden, dass es zu so einer Art Knebelvertragssituation wird. Und das ist ja ein Missbrauch von einem Vertrag, den man schon auch, finde ich, in Deutschland mal klar regeln könnte. Auch da fehlt ehrlich gesagt gerade die Reaktion. Also genau.
Ja und gleichzeitig das, was ihr gesagt habt, dass so ein NDA nicht im luftleeren Raum hängt. Also zwei Dinge, glaube ich, muss man da noch verdeutlichen. Das eine ist, die Formulierung in so NDAs, die können sehr drastisch sein. Also ich habe schon einige mal im Leben unterzeichnet, den komischsten Umständen. Und da standen zum Teil Vertragsstrafen von 100.000 Euro drin. Und das macht einem selbst ein bisschen Angst. Und auch diese Allgemeingültigkeit generell darf man, man verpflichtet sich gegenüber Dritten usw. Das ist ein sehr starker Rechtstext, der selbst, glaube ich, erfahrenere, also mit dem Recht erfahrenere Menschen einschüchtern wurde. Und das andere aber eben, es ist eben nicht so, dass man sich in einem gütlichen Gespräch am Küchentisch einigt, sich zu trennen und dann ach, übrigens ich habe noch was mitgebracht, ich habe hier noch eine Verschwiegenheitserklärung. Sondern da sind Dinge vorher passiert und es sind an Dinge, sie können an Dinge gekoppelt sein, wie eben zum Beispiel Zahlungen, wie eben zum Beispiel auch Sorgerecht usw. Dinge. Das heißt, wenn man sich eben die Frage stellt, warum unterschreiben denn diese Frauen überhaupt diese NDAs? Ich glaube, da gibt es viel mehr Gründe, als man sich erstmal so ausmalen könnte, warum man das dann tut.
Absolut und viele verbinden ja auch NDAs. Also wenn man mal davon schon gehört hat, klingt das so nach wie, ja, man verkauft halt seine Geschichte oder es ist so Schweigen gegen Geld und als wäre das dann so ein klarer Deal, der auch so freiwillig abläuft. So habe ich das eigentlich in keiner der Fälle wahrgenommen, dass das die Motivation war. Also teilweise sind das dann Abschnitte in einem Trennungsvertrag. Da geht es vielleicht auch teilweise dann darum, dass man auf den ehemaligen Partner zugeht und sagt, hier, ich versichere dir hiermit, dass ich nicht zu den Medien gehe. Eigentlich alle, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, haben auch gesagt, wir hatten nie vor, sozusagen so dreckige Wäsche bei den Medien zu waschen und dachten deswegen, ich kann das unterschreiben. Die haben das gar nicht teilweise so überblickt, in was für eine ganz schreckliche Lage dieser NDA sie dann später bringen würde, weil sie halt nur daran gedacht haben, der andere will sich absichern, nicht in den Medien auf die und die Art vorzukommen. Und wenn man das dann eh nicht vorhat, denkt man vielleicht auch so, okay, ich kann das so machen, weil eben wie gesagt ja auch nicht immer Geld geflossen ist. Und das finde ich auch nochmal wichtig, um zu verstehen und da nicht wieder so einen Vorwurf daraus zu formulieren von so, naja, sie hätte den Vertrag ja nun auch nicht unterschreiben müssen. Und wie jetzt im Fall von Kashalin hat, ist ja auch offenbar da, dass jetzt auch nicht in einem ganz harmonisch freiwilligen Gespräch abgelaufen, sondern da ist ja sehr, sehr starker Druck auf sie ausgeübt worden offenbar.
Und das führt eben so weit, dass im Harvey Weinstein-Fall wurde so ein Fall bekannt, die ich mir deshalb auch gemerkt habe, wo eine Frau, die einen NDA wegen eines Missbrauchsfalls, den er an ihr begangen hat bei ihrer Therapeutin, sich nicht mal getraut hat, vor der Therapeutin darüber zu sprechen. Also so tief, letztlich auch in die Seele, greifen diese NDAs ein, dass man dann nicht mal mehr in diesem geschützten – eigentlich sollte es ein geschützter Ort sein – sich öffnen kann. Jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, noch so einen weiteren Mechanismus, auf den wir kurz eingehen sollten. Denn immer, wenn das Wort Unschuldsvermutung bei Twitter trendet, dann kann man sich sicher sein, irgendein Mann wurde angeschuldigt, etwas getan zu haben und ganz oft hat es dann auch mit Missbrauch zu tun. Und dann kommt immer die Unschuldsvermutung hoch. Und ihr müsst ja auch mit der Unschuldsvermutung arbeiten. Ihr werdet das sehr genau abgewogen haben, was ihr in euren Texten veröffentlichen konntet und was nicht. Was möchtet ihr denn solchen Menschen sagen, die jetzt eben die Anonymität, unter denen die Frauen sich geäußert haben, gegen sie verwenden möchten, indem sie sagen, na ja, wenn die sich jetzt nicht dahinstellt und das jetzt nochmal alles so belegt und es da kein Verfahren gibt, dann müsste man ja die Unschuld vermuten.
Also ich finde, die Unschuldsvermutung ist ein mega hohes Gut und eine total wichtige Grundlage in unserer demokratischen, freiheitlichen Gesellschaft, dass es die gibt. Man muss aber auch sagen, dass bei Fällen von häuslicher Gewalt oder generell Gewalt gegen Frauen – und das haben wir nun auch mehrfach gesehen – das Rechtssystem oftmals zu kurz greift, muss man tatsächlich sagen. Also man kann – das betrifft jetzt auch nicht nur Fußballerfrauen – das betrifft generell Frauen von häuslicher Gewalt. Da gibt es ganz viele Rechtsexpertinnen und Rechtsexpertinnen, die sagen, dass der rechtliche Schutz für die Opfer eigentlich bei Weitem nicht weit genug geht. Und ganz oft hat man eben so eine Situation von Aussage gegen Aussage. Und man muss ja auch sagen, dass es für uns Medien gilt, gelten die Regeln der zulässigen Verdachtsberichterstattung. Daran haben wir uns gehalten und das haben wir wirklich ziemlich genau abgezirkelt, dass wir – Maike hat das vorhin schon erklärt – wir haben in keinem Fall einfach uns irgendwas erzählen lassen und das dann brav aufgeschrieben von anonymen Quellen, sondern wir haben wirklich sehr viele Belege dafür. Wir haben Dokumente, Fotos, Gerichtsdokumente, Textnachrichten, Besprechprotokolle. Wir haben auch mit Zeuginnen und Zeugen gesprochen. Wir haben Bilder und Dokumente, die die Verletzungen dieser Frauen dokumentieren. Es ist wirklich nicht so, dass wir aus dem hohlen Bauch eben mal so was aufgeschrieben haben, weil sich das irgendwie gut anhört, sondern es gibt Vorwürfe, über die man rechtlich zulässig Bericht erstatten kann. Dazu gehört natürlich auch, dass man die Gegenseite anhört und das entsprechend berücksichtigt. Das haben wir zumindest in den Fällen, wo wir die Frauen nicht insoweit schützen mussten, dass selbst das nicht möglich war. Aber diese Frauen kommen eben auch nur relativ knapp zur Sprache. Aber in den anderen Fällen haben wir das gemacht. Aber da hatten wir jetzt auch nicht das Gefühl, dass da großes Interesse war, die Gegenversion zu erzählen, sondern da bekamen wir dann Post von Anwälten, die eigentlich pauschal nur abgestritten haben und nicht auf einzelne Vorwürfe eingegangen sind und mit den rechtlichen Konsequenzen von einer unzulässigen Verdachtsberichterstattung gedroht haben. Also es gilt die Unschuldsvermutung, ja natürlich. Es gilt aber auch für die Frauen ein Anspruch darauf, dass man sie mal anhört und dass sie auch das Recht haben, wenn ihnen Unrecht passiert ist, dass man das zur Kenntnis nimmt und dass man als Journalistin sich eben auch damit auseinandersetzt auf eine verantwortungsvolle und medienrechtskonforme Art und Weise.
Und es geht doch auch darum, wenn wir wollen, dass sich da etwas ändert und eventuell solche Geschichten auch anders verlaufen können, dann müssen wir auch dafür sorgen, dass das überhaupt erstmal besprochen werden kann. Und natürlich in einem für alle Seiten fairen Raum. Und da stimme ich komplett mit Gabriela überein. Die Unschuldsvermutung ist ganz, ganz wichtig. Die hat eine riesen Berechtigung und die wurde hier aber auch berücksichtigt.
Sonst wäre keine eurer Texte mehr online. So kann man es doch eigentlich sagen, oder? Also das ist ja unser journalistischer Blick. Wir sehen, wenn so ein Text mit all diesen Details online stehen bleibt, länger, dann ist das wirklich wasserdicht. Denn als Journalist hat man ja fast eher so die – oder man kann zumindest davon ausgehen – ich habe immer so in meinem Kopf eigentlich dann oft die Dinge, die wahrscheinlich noch nicht erzählt werden konnten, weil sie nicht gut genug belegt werden konnten. Weil man gerade bei so langen Recherchen eigentlich weiß, dass ihr da geschrieben habt, das war nicht so, dass ihr da jetzt jeden Textfixe zusammengesucht habt, den ihr hattet, sondern ganz im Gegenteil, ihr hattet wahrscheinlich ein ganzes Konvolut und musstet es dann runterbrechen wirklich auf die Dinge, die eindeutig für euch belegbar sind, wo ihr eben dann eben auch eurer Rolle gerecht werden könnt, eurer Verantwortung, die ihr habt.
Das trifft zu, aber also meine Erfahrung aus dem Investigativ-Journalismus ist tatsächlich so, dass es kommt immer drauf an, ob sich die gegnerische Seite einen Vorteil verspricht, wenn sie jetzt dagegen vorgeht. Also es ist natürlich so, wenn man nach so einem Text, der wirklich harte Vorwürfe gegen ziemlich mächtige und einflussreiche Menschen erhebt, dass da kann man eigentlich erwarten, dass irgendetwas zurückkommt. Wir haben wirklich tatsächlich auch deshalb uns zurückgehalten, irgendwelche Vorwürfe, die jetzt tatsächlich allein auf Aussagen beruhen, sondern wir haben in den meisten Fällen eben noch Dokumente, die die Aussagen stützen und das ist eben sehr, sehr wichtig. Das heißt nicht, dass sie nicht trotzdem dagegen vorgehen können.
Das soll ja auch so sein, das gehört dazu im Rechtsstaat dazu.
Das gehört dazu, wobei natürlich irgendwie, das in meiner Erfahrung, das nimmt schon sehr stark überhand die Presse-Rechtsanwälte, die also extrem aggressiv vorgehen und die zum Teil auch sich durch mehrere Landgerichte klagen. Ich weiß das über einen Fall, wo es auch um einen gewalttätigen Fußballer geht, dessen Anwälte haben, in mehreren Landgerichten versucht, eine einstweilige Verfügung zu erreichen, bis sie schließlich einen gefunden haben, wo es durchgegangen ist. Und da muss man sich tatsächlich auch mal fragen, ob diese Möglichkeit, dass man irgendwo klagen kann, dann noch mal, dann noch mal, bis man alle 16 Bundesländer vielleicht durch hat, ob das wirklich so eine Gerechtigkeit herstellt. Also da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Das ist auch wieder ein Beispiel, wie man mit einem innovativen Ansatz eine Berichterstattung verhindern kann. Und eben genau die Frage ist, ob das jetzt dazu führt, dass da die richtigen Dinge besprochen werden können und die richtigen auch vielleicht nicht.
Man wird immer bei Gewalt gegen Frauenfällen oder geschlechtsspezifischer Gewaltfällen, nennen wir es MeToo oder einfach Gewalt, dann wird man immer wieder das Problem haben, dass man in diesen rechtlich etwas unsicheren Bereich reinkommt, weil letztlich ist es so, dass sich viele Dinge eben nicht hundertprozentig zweifelsfrei und unwiderlegbar belegen lassen. Und die Frage ist natürlich jedes Mal, wie sorgfältig bin ich als Journalistin, mir die Glaubwürdigkeit der Person zuzusichern, wie relevant ist diese Geschichte? Und es geht ja auch nicht gegen irgendwelche privaten Menschen, es geht gegen Leute, die prominente sind, die eine Vorbildfunktion, denen das zumindest zugeschrieben wird und die mit ihrem Image sehr, sehr viel Geld verdienen. Und wenn in der im Privatleben so ein Ausmaß von Gewalt oder Machtbrissbrauch stattfindet, dann bin ich absolut der Meinung, dass das ein öffentliches Interesse hat, weil das, also wie gesagt, es geht auch nicht nur um die einzelnen Spieler, es geht um die Strukturen und es geht um den ganzen Überbau. Und das ist eine Reaktion, die ich von einem Kollegen hatte, der sehr viel zu Kindesmissbrauch durch Pfarrer und Pastoren gemacht hat. Der hat die Recherche gelesen und gesagt, das ist ja wie in der katholischen Kirche. Und das ist tatsächlich der Eindruck, den man haben kann, wenn man sich anguckt, was da alles getan wird, um die mutmaßlichen Täter zu decken.
Und das ist kein Vergleich, den man haben möchte. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es gerade überhaupt noch einen Vergleich gibt, wenn man wie die katholische Kirche sein möchte. Vielleicht so alt wie die katholische Kirche. Vielleicht ist das noch der einzige Vergleich, den man gerade haben möchte. Jetzt haben wir damit schon so ein bisschen gestreift die juristische Reaktion auf eure Veröffentlichung. Und vorher waren wir schon mal ganz kurz beim Thema, aber da würde ich noch gerne mal den Fokus drauf lenken. Wie haben denn die Vereine, die Berater und so weiter reagiert? Also im Großen das System Fußball. Was waren die Reaktionen, die ihr da bekommen habt?
Also es ist überhaupt sehr, sehr schwer, auch da auch nur mal ein Hintergrundgespräch hinzubekommen. Also tatsächlich, ich weiß gar nicht, Gabriela, ob sich bei dir daraufhin jemand aus diesen Strukturen gemeldet hat oder auch nur jetzt mal irgendwie sich konstruktiv damit auseinandergesetzt hat. Da ist großes Schweigen. Und grundsätzlich hat sich da jetzt niemand bei uns gemeldet und gesagt, er oder sie würde gerne in den Diskurs einsteigen. Auch nicht die – ich weiß noch mal – die Diversitätsbeauftragte des DFB zum Beispiel. Vielleicht theoretisch so eine Person, die sich dieses Themas annehmen könnte. Auch da kam jetzt keine Reaktion.
Also wir haben ja verschiedene Vereine angefragt. Wir haben den DFB angefragt und wir haben tatsächlich nur extrem schmallippige Antworten bekommen. Also ich habe jetzt nicht den Eindruck, dass da Gesprächsbedarf besteht. Ich habe eher den Eindruck, dass sich da ganz viele Leute gerade totstellen und hoffen, dass das Thema möglichst schnell wieder aus den Schlagzeilen verschwindet. Es wird aber einen zweiten Teil geben, so schnell wird es nicht gehen.
Das kann ich schon mal versprechen. Sowieso merkt man ja jetzt, dass da offenbar noch sehr, sehr viel mehr mit dranhängt und dass das ja auch die Aufmerksamkeit zeigt, dass es da vielleicht auch eine bestimmte Identifikation oder auch ein Wiedererkennen und so weiter gibt. Was ich daran nicht ganz verstehe, ist jetzt an diesem Ausbleiben der Reaktion oder dass dieser Diskurs dann genau vor den Toren der Fußballwelt haltmacht, sozusagen die öffentliche. Es geht doch jetzt auch gar nicht darum, jetzt Schuldige zu finden. Man könnte sich ja auch so darüber irgendwie verständigen oder damit auseinandersetzen, zu sagen, okay, offenbar haben da bestimmte Fälle stattgefunden. Was können wir denn tun, damit diese Geschichten anders verlaufen und damit auch unsere Branche da – ich will jetzt nicht so weit gehen zu sagen – in eine vorbildliche, aber in so eine vorbildlich-hörer Funktion kommt und damit ja auch wieder – eben, das hat ja so sehr Vorbildskarakter, diese ganze Sportwelt, also auch einfach für so viele Menschen. Und das dann auch mal ernst zu nehmen und zu sagen, okay, wie gehen wir denn mit einer Krise, mit einem Problem in unseren Strukturen um? Und da kann man ja auch konstruktiv mit umgehen. Also es geht uns jetzt nicht darum, dass Vereine sich bei uns melden und sagen, ja, das sind wir übrigens, das ist unser Problem, sondern halt eben zu sagen so, okay, wie sehen unsere Strukturen aus? Gibt es da Angebote? Und wenn nicht, was könnten wir tun? Da könnte man ja auch mal ganz neue Wege gehen.
Also ich meine, man könnte ja schon so ganz einfache Dinge tun, was in zum Beispiel vielen Organisationen und Unternehmen normal ist, dass man Ansprechpartner für Menschen hat, die sexualisierte oder körperliche oder seelische Gewalt erleben, die unabhängig ist. Also in den Fällen, die uns vorliegen, die Frauen sind zum Teil zu dem Berater des Mannes gegangen, um Hilfe zu bekommen bei häuslicher Gewalt. Das ist eigentlich schon eine Absurdität, weil das natürlich – also da kann man auch zum Frosch gehen und sagen, leg mal den Sumpf trocken – es ist der komplett falsche Ansprechpartner. Wir haben da SMS-Wechsel, die wirklich jeglicher Beschreibung spotten, wo dann der Berater antwortet, Fotos bekommt von massiven Hämatomen und Prellungen und schreibt zurück, das sieht nicht schön aus. Ich kann jetzt aber nicht sagen, wer von euch der Gute und der Böse ist. Aber wenn du mal reden willst, komm jederzeit zu mir. Oder die Frau natürlich auch sagt, vielen Dank dafür, ich fahr jetzt ins Krankenhaus.
Und dann aber auch oft schon noch mit einschließt, dass vielleicht jetzt zur Polizei gehen nun ja nicht nötig ist. Das kann man ja sozusagen so in der Familie erklären.
Genau, also in dem Fall gibt der Wechsel auch her, dass irgendjemand Anzeige bei der Polizei erstattet hat. Also möglicherweise, keine Ahnung, Leute, die das mitgekriegt haben. Aber wo dann die Frau auch sich anscheinend zu rechtfertigen hat, wer denn da die Polizei alarmiert hat. Also das ist schon bemerkenswert. Und das zeigt aber auch auf, wie stark diesen Frauen ein Ansprechpartner fehlt, wenn man sich an die Berater des Fußballers wendet. Aber gut, die sind natürlich auch permanent im Leben, dieser Männer präsent und auch in privaten Umfällen. Aber das zeigt halt tatsächlich, wenn es eine Ombudsfrau gebe oder eine Beratungsstelle, die kann ja auch gerne an den Verein angegliedert sein oder an den Verband oder was auch immer. Einfach eine Telefonnummer, die man wählen kann und wo dann irgendwie niedrigschwellige Hilfe möglich ist. Aber das gibt es eben nicht. Und da frage ich mich natürlich schon, was spricht denn dagegen, so etwas zu machen?
Ja und einfach, ich meine, es geht einfach nur darum, einen geschützten Raum herzustellen, in dem nicht der Schutz des Image des Profifußballers an allererster Stelle steht, sondern vielleicht einfach erstmal ein neutraler Raum, in dem man vielleicht eine ganz einfache Hilfe und vielleicht Beratung erstmal bekommt. Und wie gesagt, das ist ja jetzt in anderen Bereichen schon normal und existiert. Das ist ja umsetzbar, ja.
Ja und gleichzeitig finde ich, es gibt da immer eine sehr einfache Argumentation im Sportjournalismus, sowohl auf Seiten von Journalistinnen als auch von Seiten von Beteiligten aus dem Fußballkosmos, die sagen, ja wir machen ja nur Sport, wir konzentrieren uns auf den Sport. Unsere Aufgabe ist ja nur, wir wollen ja nur sicherstellen, dass der gut trainieren kann, dass der beim nächsten Spiel fit ist. Nur deshalb ist das für uns überhaupt relevant, aber ansonsten ja gar nicht. Und ich finde, das kann man halt so eigentlich auch nicht stehen lassen, weil das würde ja, dem würde ja dann widersprechen, warum denn dann zum Beispiel die Partnerinnen von Spielern so wichtig sind bei öffentlichen Anlässen, warum die da dann so gerne genutzt werden, warum die auch, also ich will jetzt nicht den Verein vorwerfen, dass die Freikarten ins Stadion bekommen, soweit möchte ich nicht gehen, aber es ist eben nicht so, dass die Vereine nur von dem Mann profitieren, sondern es gibt eben auch Konstellationen, in denen auch die Partnerin eine wichtige Rolle spielt und gleichzeitig tragen ja auch die Frauen zu einem Image bei der Spieler und auch davon profitieren die Vereine indirekt. Und ich finde das erstaunlich, dass das immer wieder nicht über diese sehr einfachen Argumente hinausgeht. Also das hört man immer wieder und ich vermute, sowas hat man auch schon vor 20 Jahren gesagt. Also gerade dieses Argument auch, wir wollen uns ja auf den Sport konzentrieren, das ist wahrscheinlich so uralt wie der Sportjournalismus selbst schon, aber das ist ja wahnsinnig kurz gedacht und es ist erstaunlich, dass man damit bis heute eigentlich noch sehr häufig wenig Widerspruch hat.
Das ist ein Alibi, also ich halte das für nicht ganz ehrlich, weil im Fußball passiert eine ganze Menge, was wirklich nicht so viel mit Sport zu tun hat. Also nennen wir mal diese ganze Vermarktung, die Werbung, die Sponsoren, all das hat nichts mit dem Sport zu tun und trotzdem ist es irgendwie etwas, worum sich die Vereine dann gerne kümmern. Die Frauen sind ja auch willkommen, solange sie irgendwie hübsche Home-Stories in den Boulevard-Medien machen. Das ist ja etwas, was durchaus encouraged wird. Dass sie da irgendwie zeigen, das ist das schöne Zuhause des Spielers und ich bin seine hübsche Frau und das sind seine süßen Kinder, weil das eben halt der Vermarktung dient. Nur in dem Moment, wo es schwierig wird, heißt es auf einmal irgendwie so, ja wir kümmern uns nur um Fußball und nimm nichts sonst. Also das ist nicht ganz ehrlich.
Und jetzt haben wir ja einen Fall, der wird öffentlich behandelt und auch deshalb haben wir ja zum Beispiel schon über Kasia Lennert und Jerome Boateng gesprochen. Es gibt jetzt gerade ein laufendes Verfahren in München gegen Jerome Boateng, ein Berufungsverfahren. Also es gab schon ein Urteil gegen ihn. Welche Rolle spielt es denn für die Situation von betroffenen Frauen, dass es jetzt diesen einen aktuellen Fall gibt, der verhandelt wird und der es ja auch Journalistinnen und Journalisten ermöglicht, auch über Details zu sprechen?
Das ist tatsächlich eine Sache, die für uns, glaube ich, wichtig war. Denn wir haben hier diesen einen Fall, wo tatsächlich eine Frau einmal Anzeige erstattet hat und wo es ein strafrechtliches Verfahren gibt, inzwischen in zweiter Instanz, was von der Münchner Staatsanwaltschaft extrem ernst genommen wird, was entsprechend auch Bericht erstattet wird, das Interesse an dem Berufungsprozess medial war ziemlich hoch. Also ich hatte das Gefühl, dass unsere Berichterstattung da auch tatsächlich ein Türspalt noch mal weiter geöffnet hat, weil der erste Prozess tatsächlich relativ dünn berichtet wurde. Und jetzt haben die Vorwürfe, die die Ex-Freundin in dem Fall erhebt, doch ziemliches Gehör gefunden. Und tatsächlich ist es so, dass natürlich, also man muss dazu sagen, dass Jérôme Boateng hat immer gesagt, dass er seine Unschuld bestreitet. Jetzt in dem Prozess äußert er sich nicht, aber sein Anwalt hat gleich zu Anfang auch noch mal gesagt, dass er jegliches strafrechtlich relevantes Tun bestreitet. Aber was die Ex-Freundin zu sagen hat, das ist doch jetzt irgendwie in der Öffentlichkeit und darüber wird gesprochen. Die Art und Weise, wie mit diesen Vorgängen umgegangen wird, ganz gleich, ob sie sich erhärten lassen oder nicht, aber die Art, wie diese Frau befragt wurde, wie sie immer wieder auch intimste Details preisgeben musste. Es gab diesen Vorfall, wo die Bodyguards ja offenbar eine Zeugin, oder die Zeugin fühlte sich eingeschüchtert von den Bodyguards, weil diese Bodyguards sie ungefragt offenbar gefilmt haben. Alle diese Dinge sind jetzt draußen. Darüber wird geredet und das ist auch tatsächlich sehr gut so.
Und genau dieser Fall ist jetzt einmal ein Beispiel, das alle mit beobachten können, aber einsortiert in dieses Strukturelle, was wir jetzt in der Recherche darstellen konnten. Und ganz vieles lässt sich da auch sehr, sehr gut einsortieren. Und jetzt geht es aber nicht darum zu sagen, der Fall von Jerome Boateng ist in sich beispielhaft für vieles. Aber das, was rundherum die Mechanismen, die greifen, die Strukturen, die bedient werden, dieses Machtungleichgewicht, all das lässt sich daran sehr, sehr gut erkennen. Und es ist natürlich jetzt auch nochmal spannend, das Ganze zu betrachten, wenn dieses Berufungsverfahren dann abgeschlossen ist, denke ich, und dann nochmal zu diskutieren, wie die Resonanz ist, wie sich das alles abgespielt hat und was wir daraus für Schlüsse, auch für diesen strukturellen Machtmissbrauch ziehen können.
Richtig. Also was uns, glaube ich, wichtig ist, wir wollen jetzt nicht uns auf Boateng konzentrieren. Boateng ist ein Fußballer, gegen den gleich mehrere Frauen Vorwürfe erhoben haben. Einmal Kascha Lehnhardt und dann die Frau, die jetzt im Berufungsprozess auch wieder aufgesagt hat. Und die Vorwürfe stehen einfach im Raum. Es gibt dazu Ermittlungsverfahren und die kann man jetzt einfach nicht mehr wegdiskutieren. Letztlich aber geht es uns überhaupt nicht um die Person Jerome Boateng, weil es gibt mehrere andere Fußballer, wo teilweise Anzeigen erstattet wurden, teilweise nicht, die jetzt aber nicht in der Öffentlichkeit sind bisher, die aber auf eine ganz ähnliche Art und Weise operiert haben und wo ganz ähnliche Strategien auch zum Tragen kamen.
Und trotzdem ist es halt eben jetzt extrem interessant zu sehen, wie, also ich meine zum Beispiel diese Situation, in der die Bodyguards von Jerome Boateng es für eine gute Idee halten, im Kontext einer Gerichtsverhandlung eine relevante Zeugin zu filmen, die sich dann dadurch unter Druck gesetzt fühlt. Das ist ja, das zeigt für mich dieses Selbstverständnis und auch dieser, ja, also das Selbstvorgericht. Der Eindruck da ist, dass andere Regeln für einen gelten, und man so ein bisschen eventuell auch sich unantastbar fühlt und so eine Konsequenzlosigkeit für selbstverständlich nimmt. Und dann, ja, also dass die einfach diese, ja, so eine Art rechtsfreier Raum gefühlt entsteht um jemanden und das vor Gericht. Das ist schon interessant auch als Fallhöhe für das, was wir beschrieben haben vorher als strukturelles Problem, dass sich allerdings eben nicht nur auf Jerome Boateng bezieht, sondern auch viele andere.
Das war eine interessante Inszenierung. Dieser Mann, dieser Fußballer, der reinkommt, begleitet von drei Bodyguards und ich glaube drei oder vier Anwälten, wo die Ex-Freundin auf der anderen Daseite sitzt mit ihrer einen Anwältin, das schafft gleich vor Gericht so einen Eindruck von, also Waffengleichheit ist das nicht. Boateng hat nicht ausgesagt, er saß die ganze Zeit schweigend da und hat seine Anwälte für ihn reden lassen. Und die Frau musste sich, auf Deutsch gesagt, komplett loslegen. Also mit allem, was ihr passiert ist, mit allem, was auch die Beziehung zu ihrem Ex-Freund Boateng angeht, bis hin zu der Frage, wann sie ihre Periode hatte und wann sie das letzte Mal Geschlechtsverkehr mit ihm hatte, vor diesem ganzen versammelten Gericht. Und das ist tatsächlich auch ein Umgang mit Frauen, die Gewalt erlebt haben oder entsprechende Vorwürfe erheben, wo ich glaube, dass unser Rechtssystem sich dringend auch ändern muss.
Absolut. Und das Ganze muss man sich ja auch mal vorstellen, das was Gabriela hier gerade beschrieben hat, also diese wirklich das in peinlichste Details gehende Befragung, in der es dann auch natürlich von den Anwälten von Jerome Boat hängt darum, gegen ihre Glaubwürdigkeit in Frage zu stellen, sie zu diskreditieren, also um ihn zu entlasten. Das alles hat sich ja in der Öffentlichkeit abgespielt. Also da sind ja Medien waren ja eben zugelassen. Und das ist ja auch eine Situation, die man sich jetzt einfach mal auf einer menschlichen Ebene vorstellen muss. Und ja, auch da gilt wieder die Unschuldsvermutung. Aber es steht auch im Raum, dass es sich eben so abgespielt hat. Und wenn man das auch mal mit einbezieht, dass da jemand sitzt, der potentiell wirklich Traumatisches erlebt hat, der dann sich stundenlang so einer Situation aussetzen muss, in aller Öffentlichkeit darüber dann hinterher berichtet werden muss, das ist eigentlich auch noch mal ein Missstand für sich, wo man sich auch noch mal als Gesellschaft fragen muss, ob das eigentlich ein Vorgehen ist, was angemessen ist in so einer Konstellation.
Also ich sehe schon, wir werden noch mal sprechen müssen, sowohl über den Fall Boateng, der dann ja auch ein rechtsgültiges Urteil haben wird, irgendwann noch läuft da gerade die Berufungsverhandlung und dann der von euch angekündigte Teil 2 zu eurer Recherche. Das ist ein ganz komisches Gefühl. Man weiß ja gar nicht, ob man sich über so etwas freuen kann. Wahrscheinlich dann schon, weil ja etwas, was schon passiert ist, dann aufgedeckt wird und hoffentlich zu einer Verbesserung führt. Das ist natürlich die Hoffnung, die wir alle drei haben. Ich danke euch sehr für eure Zeit. Ihr seid sehr gefragte Menschen, ihr habt sehr viel zu tun. Ich weiß es wirklich zu schätzen, dass ihr euch so viel Zeit genommen habt. Herzlichen Dank an Gabriela Keller vom Correctiv als Add-Gabriela Keller auch auf Twitter. Danke dir, Gabriela, dass du hier im Rasenfunk warst. Und danke an Maike Backhaus, freie Journalistin, als Add-Maike Backhaus auch bald auf Twitter. So richtig aktiv. Danke dir, liebe Maike.
Ganz vielen Dank, dass wir hier das ganze Thema so gut besprechen konnten.
Jederzeit wieder. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, danke ich vor eurer Aufmerksamkeit. Noch einmal der Hinweis, wenn ihr mit diesem Thema Probleme habt oder betroffen seid. Es sind alle Informationen in den Shownotes verlinkt. Ich freue mich auf Feedback zu dieser Sendung unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und im sozialen Netzwerk eurer Wahl. Wir sind eigentlich überall vertreten. Und in diesem Sinne bleibt gesund, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, bleibt dem Rasenfunk treu. Und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch. Macht's gut.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.